la présidente marielle de sarnez a reçu
ce matin une lettre du président richard
ferrand demandant à la commission de
désirs ses représentants dans le mandat
est arrivé à échéance
des conseils d'administration
d'organismes extérieurs
nous devons ainsi désigner un député
siégeant au conseil d'administration de
campus france
je suis saisi de la candidature de
frédéric petit pour le renouvellement de
son mandat qui s'est achevé le 17
octobre dernier qui est pour et qui est
contre et qui s'abstient à l'unanimité
en application de l'article 6 de la loi
du 27 juin 2010 relative à l'action
extérieure de l'état
la commission des affaires étrangères a
désigné monsieur frédéric petit pour
siéger pour un nouveau mandat de trois
ans au conseil d'administration de
campus france
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir de retrouver parmi nous cet
après midi monsieur jean yves le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères pour une audition qui portera
d'une part sur deux projets de loi
importants dans la commission est saisie
ou va l'être prochainement
et d'autre part sur l'actualité
internationale
le calendrier législatif dans notre
commission est en effet marqué en cette
fin d'année par l'examen de deux projets
de loi de grande importance
il s'agit en premier lieu de celui
autorisant la ratification de l'accord
de coopération avec l'union monétaire
ouest africaine uemoa qui sera examiné
en séance publique le jeudi 10 décembre
sur le rapport de notre collègue
jean-françois mbaye notre collègue
soutient cet accord il s'est rendu à
dakar pour en évaluer les termes je lui
donnerai la parole après votre
intervention il a des propositions
constructives pour associer les élus et
les sociétés civiles à ce grand projet
économique d'accord conclu le 21
décembre 2019 constitue en effet une
réforme monétaire majeur il faut
remonter à 75 ans avec la création du
franc cfa pour trouver une réforme de
cette ampleur en afrique notre pays
se retire à des instances de gestion de
la future monnaie renommée échos le
trésor français ne centralisera plus les
réserves de change mais la france
maintiendra sa garantie financière pour
couvrir les engagements en devises de la
banque centrale des états de l'afrique
de l'ouest
cette réforme nous va moderniser l'union
monétaire ouest africaine et faciliter
son extension à d'autres pays membres de
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest
la nouvelle zone monétaire de l'écho va
ainsi permettre une véritable
restructuration des marchés de l'afrique
de l'ouest
nous souhaiterions monsieur le ministre
que vous nous indiquez les enjeux de cet
accord de coopération pour la france le
second projet de loi dont va être saisi
notre commission et celui autorisant
l'approbation de la décision du conseil
européen sur les systèmes des ressources
propres à l'union européenne
pierre-alexandre anglais on sera le
rapporteur il s'est investi dans sa
mission sans attendre car ces nouvelles
ressources constitue une avancée
importante pour l'union européenne
je lui donnerai également la parole
après votre intervention
ces ressources vont financer une partie
du plan de relance européen
au-delà de l'enjeu économique
considérable
ce plan de nouvelles ressources traduit
l'engagement des européens en faveur du
développement durable et leur volonté de
mettre en place un prélèvement sur les
échanges numériques et sur les
transactions financières l'adoption de
ce plan de relance européen est
actuellement bloqué par la hongrie et la
pologne et peut-être par la slovénie
nous souhaiterons monsieur le ministre
entendre votre analyse sur la situation
et les perspectives d'aboutissement
d'ici au conseil européen des 10 et 11
décembre
croyez vous à un accord possible et si
oui sous quelles conditions
l'autre sujet européen majeur sur lequel
nous souhaiterions vous entendre et le
break site
allons nous vers en accord ou une
absence d'accord en cas d'accord quelles
seraient les termes acceptables pour la
france en matière de pêche d'accès au
marché d'équité de concurrence de
gouvernance du futur partenariat
en cas d'absence
d'accord comment mettre en place ces
nouvelles relations avec le royaume uni
et dans quel cadre juridique
l'actualité internationale est bien
entendu ces jours ci dominé par le
conflit au karabagh la france joue un
rôle important en tant que coprésidente
du groupe de minsk cette guerre de six
semaines s'est traduite par
d'importantes pertes civiles et
militaires des déplacements de
population considérable des destructions
il est à présent indispensable de faire
respecter le cessez le feu
d'apporter une aide aux populations en
ouvrant des couloirs humanitaires de
protéger les patrimoines culturels et
religieux sur le conflit lui-même
êtes vous optimiste un règlement négocié
vous paraît-il possible nous nous
interrogeons également sur les ambitions
de la turquie dans le caucase et sur la
stratégie de l'iran qui n'a pas essayé
de retenir l'azerbaïdjan dans son
offensive
enfin monsieur le ministre nous
souhaiterions vous entendre sur les
conséquence vraisemblable au plan
international du changement
d'administration américaine le 20
janvier prochain
il est peu problable probable car
virmont soit observée dans les relations
avec la chine en revanche
qu'attendez vous de la nouvelle
administration en matière de
multilatéralisme notamment dans la
conduite de l'otan au sein de l' oms ou
de l'om c'est dans la lutte contre les
changements climatiques et la crise
sanitaire international en outre quelle
est votre position face au désengagement
partiel en afghanistan et en irak
annoncés par le président donald trump
mes collègues auront sans doute à coeur
d'aborder beaucoup d'autres sujets mais
nous allons à présent vous écoutez je
vous sais de la parole monsieur le
ministre
c'est toujours du temps pour vous je
crois que je viens tous les mois il ya
monsieur le président je voudrais
d'abord que vous puissiez transmeta la
présidente de sarnez tous mes voeux de
rétablissement et toute notre amitié et
notre soutien dans son épreuve
mesdames et messieurs les députés
devraient revenir un peu dans mon
intervention monsieur le président sur
en fait un point commun que l'on peut
distinguer dans une bonne partie de vos
questions pas tout
le point commun est la question qui
majeur qui est posée c'est la question
de la détermination des européens à
prendre leur avenir en main en affirmant
à la fois leurs intérêts leurs valeurs
mais aussi leur volonté d'agir et d'être
présent sur la scène internationale
c'est ce qui est en jeu dans l'adoption
de notre plan de relance européen
c'est ce qui est en jeu dans les
négociations du brds excite c'est ce qui
est en jeu aussi dans notre réponse au
défi des jeux de puissance qui sont à
l'oeuvre à nos frontières
c'est ce qui est en jeu aussi dans le
nouveau partenariat transatlantique que
nous devrons travailler à construire
avec la prochaine administration
américaine
et c'est ce qui est en jeu aussi dans
notre relation à l'afrique relation que
nous avons à réinventer avec nos
partenaires de ce continent et le
chantier monétaire sur lequel vous
m'avez interrogées est un jalon
important sur ce chemin une seule et
même question est ce que les européens
peuvent prendre leur avenir en main avec
eux je crois
quelques signes positifs que je voudrais
identifié deux devant vous depuis notre
dernière rencontre autour de deux
questions qui sont aujourd'hui au coeur
de l'actualité des préoccupations des
français qui sont la crise sanitaire
d'une part et la campagne de haine dont
nous sommes victimes du jeudi nous les
européens
campagne de haine qui le savons que trop
fait le lit de la violence terroriste et
donc je voudrais revenir sur ces deux
points avant de repasser en revue
quelques observations que vous m'avez
suggéré de faire sur plusieurs sujets
liés à cette seule question concernant
la crise sanitaire
l'europe et la crise sanitaire je veux
dire que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous
en parler
vous savez que nous avons d'emblée tout
fait pour pousser l'europe à agir bien
que la santé publique ne fasse pas
partie des compétences de l'union
européenne
mais la crise a montré de manière très
claire que sans une europe de la santé
il n'y a pas d'europe qui protège et
donc il n'y a pas d'europe pleinement
maître de son destin et c'est d'autant
plus vrai aujourd'hui qu'à l'instar de
notre pays l'europe toute entière est
confrontée à la deuxième vague qui nous
frappe de plein fouet et tout cela forme
une exigence que nous garderons à
l'esprit dans la perspective de la
présidence française au premier semestre
mais je trouve que grâce aux et à nos
efforts aux efforts de tous il y a eu
des dvd progrès qui ont été accomplis au
cours de ces derniers mois dans dans le
domaine de lutte contre la pandémie
d'abord grâce à notre mobilisation les
frontières européennes sont gérés de
manière coordonnée
je vous rappelle que leurs robes de
début de la pandémie il y a eu des
actions un peu en tous les sens qui
était mené chacun de son côté
là maintenant depuis mi mars il y à des
engagements clairs qui ont été pris en
commun les frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne sont toutes fermées
je leur dis parce que parfois on oublie
de nos réaffirmé de le dire que ça
fonctionne comme ça
disons que ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça
puisque les frontières sont fermées donc
on ne rendent pas sauf
aux européens qui résident en europe
dire des français par exemple qui
veulent rentrer chez ceux peuvent le
faire on a eu déjà l'occasion de les
accompagner dans cette démarche mais les
frontières extérieures sont fermés
ensemble et à l'intérieur de l'espace
européen
nous avons mis en place un dispositif de
coordination qui nous permet de laisser
les frontières ouvertes tout en
maîtrisant les risques sanitaires donc
c'est un avancé assez significative par
rapport à ce que nous avons connu nous
avons élaboré une cartographie qui
permet à zonage de l'épidémie et un
accord sur les mesures sanitaires
nécessaires tester quarantaine
travaillons actuellement à l'élaboration
de règles communes sur les tests même
qui devrait être prête pour le conseil
européen de décembre s'est avancé je
prends était importante à annoter et
nous travaillons je le dis peut-être un
peu sur certaines préoccupations de
spatiale nous travaillons aussi en ce
moment même sur l'harmonisation des
politiques à l'égard des stations de ski
par exemple parce qu'il ya des espaces
skiables qui sont communs plusieurs pays
européens donc avancer l'appui sur la
question des vaccins nous avons aussi
nettement progressé depuis quelques
semaines où on par rapport à la première
à la première premier confinement la
première vague vous souvenez de ce qui
était à ce moment là la concurrence sur
les masses la concurrence sur le sur les
blues et nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une logique de coordination pour éviter
que la concurrence entre nos états
puissent aboutir à une espèce de
nationalisme vaccinale qui n'apporterait
pas de solution c'est pourquoi nous
avons décidé de mutualiser les achats et
nous avons demandé à la commission de
négocier des contrats avec deux
laboratoires de manière à pouvoir
réserver par avance des doses de vaccins
pour l'ensemble des européens en
veillant à diversifier notre bouquet de
vaccins pour répondre aux besoins
spécifiques de toutes les populations et
de pouvoir disposer de toutes les
technologies dans ac2 à ce jour cinq
contrats ont été signés
comme l'annoncé madame van der leyen et
un nouveau contrat a été signé
aujourd'hui modern normalement et un
septième est en cours de négociation
donc ça représente un milliard et demi
de doses qui permettra de répondre aux
besoins de 853 millions de personnes et
il est acté qu'avec la projection que
préconisé par l' oms 40% de la
population sera sera vacciné et alors
que la préconisation oms et de -20% dont
nous sommes dans une logique positive
c'est des orientations encourageantes
même s'il convient de rester prudent
concernant les vaccins puisque il faudra
attendre les résultats définitifs
puisque pour l'instant nous avons des
résultats préliminaires et les
autorisations de mise en marché ne sont
pas encore accordé il appartiendra à l'
agence européenne du médicament de se
prononcer et il vient d'indiquer qu'elle
le fera avant la fin de l'année nous
mettons donc tout en oeuvre pour être
prêt dès qu'un vaccin arrivera
effectivement sur le marché et d'éviter
des concurrence inutile il ya là donc
une capacité d'anticipation qui est qui
est manifeste
ça se traduit aussi dans le terme de
coopération internationale parce que
chacun a bien conscience que on ne peut
pas avoir une humanité qui vivent en
bonne santé sur une planète malade et on
ne peut pas avoir un règlement de la
crise pandémique qu'ils ne soient
limités qu'un seul territoire qu'un seul
continent et donc nous devons avoir
obligatoirement une réponse mondiale est
à l'initiative dans cet esprit que qui a
été initiée l'initiative dite initiative
acta dont vous avez déjà je pense
entendu parler lancé par le président de
la république le 4 mai dernier avec le
soutien de l'union européenne pour
recueillir les fonds suffisants pour
pouvoir produire en quantité nécessaire
les vaccins les traitements et renforcer
les systèmes de santé et c'est dans
cette dynamique là aussi que nous avons
initié ce qu'on appelle la facilité
financière kovacs qui devrait permettre
de garantir un accès aux vaccins aux
pays en voie de développement
cette facilité financière initiée par
nos soins a permis déjà de réunir
plus de deux milliards d'euros et il
faudra aller au delà parce que il est
clair que la santé des impasses par la
santé de tous et il nous faut là aussi
éviter l'écueil de ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure le nationalisme vaccinale
par ailleurs depuis qu'on ne s'est vue
nous avons pu mettre en oeuvre un
objectif dont je vous avais fait part
lors de jeux croix d'or d'une de mes
auditions au précédente qui était de
créer une
un conseil d'experts de haut niveau au
niveau mondial en appui de ce que fait
le msc en relation en articulation avec
cet organisme une espèce de vieques du
de la pandémie une fillette que de santé
hasek de santé qui intègre à la fois la
dimension animale et la dimension
humaine et les désordres aviron
environnementaux afin de donner une
visibilité accrue à l'ensemble des
interrogations autour de la santé et 7
ce conseil d'experts de haut niveau
avant aura pour responsabilité de faire
écho d alerte auprès des responsables
publics mais aussi de d'informer le
grand public des enjeux de politique
sanitaire
on voit bien que c'est tout à fait
essentiel est que jusqu'à présent ça
n'existe pas
7 ce projet a été mis sur la table avec
nos amis allemands en mars dernier et
six mois après elle a été actée par les
organisations internationales et cela va
être mis en oeuvre très bientôt c'est la
preuve que quand l'europe se mobilise
lc impulser des réformes et elle peut
mettre en oeuvre un multilatéralisme
plus efficace sur ces deux sujets
nous avons obtenu des résultats aussi au
forum de paris sur la paix ce rendez
vous que nous avons lancé il ya deux ans
afin de travailler à la renforcer la
gouvernance globale en associant non
seulement les états mais aussi le
secteur privé et les forces de la
société civile
et tout cela a été prise en compte par
le forum de paris est par ailleurs lors
du g20 visuelles virtuelles qui s'est
tenu ce week le week-end dernier
nous pouvons nous réjouir que la
déclaration finale des chefs d'état et a
permis de faire en sorte que la notion
de vaccins bien public mondial soit
confortée et maintenant pour être mises
en oeuvre donc voit bien l'évolution
progressive qui s'est manifestée pour
avoir une réponse cohérente à la crise
de l'accueil de 19
il ya aussi un autre point que je
voulais souligner d'actualité concernant
l'action européenne que vous m'avez
inciter à développer dans vos propos
monsieur le président c'est la campagne
de haine qui a été menée à notre
encontre
et d'abord les partenaires européens ont
été au rendez vous pour faire bloc à nos
côtés c'était important pour pour notre
pays mais c'était aussi important pour
le repos tant que tel car ce qui est
visé par ces campagnes c'est bien le
modèle de liberté qui nous rassemble et
chacun l'a bien compris et vous avez
bien pu observer que cette campagne de
haine se poursuit il y a quelques jours
encore style week-end dernier
nous avons condamné avec la plus grande
fermeté les propos haineux proférées par
un membre du gouvernement pakistanais
qui vous tout le monde a pu suivre ça
montre que ces deux logiques là et
toujours en oeuvre et les récents
attentats ceux sur ceux survenus en
france et en autriche et mais aussi les
attaques de djeddah pour montrer à quel
point on passe très rapidement de la
haine virtuel aux pires violences
physiques et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter cet engrenage de haine et de
violence et nous avons multiplié les
contacts et les prises de parole
publiques avec un double message un
message de fermeté à destination de ceux
qui instrumentalisent ces questions à
des fins politiques et géopolitiques un
message d'apaisement à destination des
femmes et des hommes de bonne volonté du
monde musulman et nous le faisons en
tant que français mais aussi en
partageant ces initiatives avec nos
partenaires européens et nous
travaillons surtout pour combattre cette
herman à la mise en place d'une
réglementation européenne renforçant les
obligations pesant sur les plateformes
numériques pour modérer les contenus
qu'elle héberge et la bonne échelle pour
faire ça c'est l'échelle européenne
il ya deux textes qui sont en cours de
discussion et de préparation il ya
d'abord le projet de règlement dit tc
haut sur le traitement des contenus
terroristes qui est actuellement en
négociations avec le parlement européen
et qui nécessite une vraie mobilisation
pour qu'il soit adopté le plus
rapidement possible ce texte permettra
de faire retirer les contenus
terroristes en ligne dans un délai d'une
heure même si la plateforme hébergeant
le contenu se trouve dans un autre état
membre et d'autre part le projet des dds
a digital services act qui doit être
présentée par la commission début
décembre et qui permettra d'agir plus
largement sur les contenus haineux en
ligne en mettant en place un régime de
responsabilité des plateformes pour
modérer ses contenus et les retirer ces
deux initiatives très fortes que nous
soutenons et sur lequel nous mobilisons
l'ensemble de nos partenaires donc ce
sont des éléments tout ce que je viens
de dire plutôt des éléments d'optimisme
dans ce panorama général qui est assez
sombre qui montre qu' il y a toujours un
optimisme européens à mettre en oeuvre
et je voulais le souligner dans mon
propos général j'en viens maintenant que
vous n'y avez invité aux enjeux du débat
actuel sur notre plan de relance
ce plan de relance est élu aussi le
résultat de notre mobilisation face à la
crise sanitaire et à ses conséquences et
le 10 novembre dernier les négociations
avec le parlement européen sur le cadre
financier pluriannuel et sur le plan de
relance agréable en juillet par nos
chefs d'état de gouvernement parle
permis d'aboutir à un accord politique
sur ce paquet budgétaire
il a été augmentée de 15 milliards
d'euros
en plus de l'accord de juillet sur les
sept années à venir en raison de
l'intervention du parlement sur les
orientations budgétaires en particulier
dans le renforcement de dispositifs
comme erasmus plus où le programme de
l'union européenne pour la santé ou
encore le programme de recherche horizon
europe et une feuille de route renforce
également le calendrier des conseils
européens en matière d'introduction de
nouvelles ressources propres
ce que nous soutenons il ya eu aussi un
accord qui a été trouvé avec le
parlement européen sur un mécanisme de
conditionnalité financières liées à
l'état de droit qui donne au conseil la
possibilité de décider à la majorité
qualifiée une suspension des versements
de l'union européenne dès lors que des
violations de l'état de droit porterait
atteinte
aux enjeux importants de l'état de droit
et son visé essentiellement des cas de
corruption de fraude mais aussi de non
respect des valeurs fondamentales de
notre union et vous le savez vous avez
bien voulu nous rappeler le rappeler la
pologne et la hongrie en raison de leur
opposition à ce nouveau mécanisme
relatif à l'état de droit ont fait
obstacle à l'adoption des textes du
paquet budgétaire y compris la décision
ressources propres et celle ci est
essentielle car elle autorise la
commission a emprunté les 750 milliards
d'euros nécessaires pour le plan de
relance européen et emprunter sur les
marchés de capitaux et ce blocage la est
un blocage que nous regrettons parce que
il va à l'encontre de l'impératif de
solidarité européenne
pourtant extrêmement dure et elle ce
blocage va aussi à l'encontre de nos
valeurs
et comme si celle ci n'était pas le
coeur même de notre modèle car l'europe
ne sera vraiment l'europe que si elle
n'est pas uniquement un grand marché il
faut donc maintenant ma terroriste sur
les chances de réussite
je pense qu'il faut surmonter cet
obstacle en travaillant avec la
présidence allemande en travaillant avec
la commission mais aussi en travaillant
avec la pologne et la hongrie dans un
mission de conviction pour leur montrer
aussi que leur intérêt celui là quelques
chiffres pour mémoire la pologne
pourrait se voir doter de 124 milliards
d'euros au titre du nouveau cadre
financier pluriannuel et du fonds de
relance ce n'est pas rien la hongrie
elle aussi sera largement bénéficiaire
nette du budget de l'union européenne et
donc peut penser que ces arguments plus
la force de conviction que l'on peut
déployer permettront d'aboutir je
l'espère un accord au moment du conseil
européen du 10 et 11 décembre l'union
européenne unit l'unité européenne
magnifique manifester c'est aussi une
valeur cardinale essentiel dans la
dernière ligne droite des négociations
sur le break site
l'aîné gauche est l'issue de ces
négociations restent à ce moment
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés très incertaine
comme elle l'a été depuis le début de
négociations les ouvertures britannique
reste à ce jour insuffisante sur les
sujets les plus sensibles la pêche
vous l'avez dit je le répète avec force
elle ne sera pas la variable
d'ajustement de cette négociation
je le dis pour que l'on m'entende même
de l'autre côté de la manche les
positions sur l'accès aux eaux et sur
les quotas ainsi que leur périodicité
reste extrêmement éloignée des uns des
autres
londres veut toujours récupérer la
quasi-totalité des volumes pêchés par
l'union dans les eaux britanniques comme
sur l'ouverture de l'accès à la zone des
6 12 milles en manche qui fait pourtant
partie des droits historiques ce
point-là fait l'objet de discussions
elles sont loin d'être convergente des
conditions de concurrence loyale aussi
ne sont pas aujourd'hui en convergence
les garanties envisagées restent minimes
et la partie britannique s'en tient une
posture défensive sur les règles en
matière d'e tat aides d'état sur les
règles d'origine sur les standards
environnementaux ou sociaux
le principe est simple si on veut
bénéficier du marché intérieur que
représente l'union européenne il faut en
accepter les règles quand on joue au
football même sur le terrain extérieur
il faut accepter les règles sinon on
voit qu'on va pas jouer et c'est aussi
simple que cela
ou alors on sert notre sport mais si on
veut jouer à ce sport là il faut
respecter les règles et donc je le dis
aussi en europe oui voilà on ne peut pas
ne pas venir jouer au cricket and
football ça marche pas
notre position en gros si vous voulez
venir se nomme marché il faut respecter
les règles de notre marché bassino je
n'ai pas et puis il ya encore des
problèmes sur la gouvernance parce que
nous avons besoin d'un cadre
institutionnel permettant d'avoir un
mécanisme de règlement des différends
qui couvre tous les sujets par des
mesures de protection et des mesures
croisés pour s'assurer que les
engagements d un réseau soient bien
respectées donc à l'heure actuelle
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
royaume uni continuent de faire traîner
les discussions faire traîner les
discussions sur des sujets secondaires
et joue avec le calendrier
profitant du fait que ces procédures de
ratification au royaume uni sont moins
contraignantes et moins longue pour les
procédures de ratification de l'union
européenne donc du coup le jeu du
calendrier marche aussi là dessus mais
je constate avec intérêt que l'union
reste uni et même si nous sommes en
train d'étudier les procédures pour
permettre à un éventuel accord d'entrée
en application même provisoire dès le
1er janvier
ne faut pas de toute façon je dis aussi
à nos amis britanniques ne feront pas
pris mais le calendrier sur le contenu
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas et donc l'union
est certes déterminé aboutir un
partenariat aussi étroite que possible
avec le royaume uni mais il revient
alors aux britanniques de faire de
sortir des postures tactique et de faire
les gestes nécessaires et nous seront
par ailleurs intransigeance sur la
pleine et entière application de
l'accord de retrait qui a fait l'objet
de beaucoup de discussions les temps
dernier mais c'est une question de
respect des engagements pris de la
parole donnée de par le royaume uni pour
à la fois préserver l'intégrité du
marché 1 derrière et ce aussi préserver
la paix le respect des accords du
vendredi-saint sur l'île d'irlande
alors nous sommes aujourd'hui je vous le
dit prêt à tous les scénarios au niveau
européen comme au niveau national
nous avons pris à titre national
déjà par anticipation il ya longtemps on
avait déjà parlé ici les mesures
nécessaires en termes de contrôles aux
frontières de la france culture de
droits des citoyens de vérification des
normes et bien ces mesures seront
appliquées si nous sommes dans la
nécessité d'aboutir à anodine je pense
que il est parfois meilleur d'avoir ne
pas avoir d'accord que d'avoir un
mauvais accord parfois pas d'accord vaut
mieux qu'un mauvais accord
donc nous espérons qu'un accord mais
nous constatons qu aujourd'hui nous
sommes pas en phase de pouvoir l'obtenir
tels que sont l'état des négociations et
ne voulons pas nous laisser nous ne nous
laisserons pas piéger par une des jeux
de calendrier qui pourrait remettre en
cause des enjeux beaucoup plus important
qu'un calendrier
je voudrais vous dire aussi que ce
besoin
excusez moi je prends un verre d'eau
nous avons aussi besoin d'unité
européenne face à la turquie vous
connaissez l'ampleur des désaccords que
nous avons avec ce pays j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler ici à plusieurs
reprises je dis que nous avons avec ce
pays parce que quand je dis nous je
parle de l'europe
l'expansionnisme turcot méditerranée
orientale qui touche la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriales de chypre et
de la grèce et donc de l'europe toute
entière
l'instrumentalisation de la question
migratoire par le président à organe sa
touche l'europe toute entière
la politique de déstabilisation menée
par la turquie en libye en syrie en irak
en libye menée par la turquie en parlant
en libye en syrie en irak ou dans le
haut-karabagh touche l'europe toute
entière et constitue une menace pour
notre sécurité donc le moment est venu
pour la turquie de clarifier sa position
et je les dis avec sans ambiguïté depuis
déjà plusieurs semaines
le mans est venu parce que c'est le
conseil européen du 10 et 11 décembre
qui doit prendre les orientations
nécessaires
la turquie doit choisir entre la voie de
la coopération
c'est la condition d'une relation
constructive et la voie de la
confrontation
et force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
elle n'a pas saisi cette hypothèse comme
le montre le petit pique nique du
président erdogan sur la plage de
varrault chat à chypre au delà d'un
pique nique vous pensent que les membres
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de l'assemblée nationale voit bien toute
la dimension symbolique et de rupture
avec des engagements et des rues ces
accords passés dans le cadre de des
nations unies alors il y a quelques
jours j'ai pu noter une certaine
inflexion dans la tonalité des
déclarations émanant des autorités
turques
qui tranchait mais c'est quand même la
moindre des choses avec les discours
inacceptable des jours précédents mais d
inflexion du discours ne suffisent pas
ce qu'il faut ce sont des actes et des
preuves tangibles d'un vrai changement
de politique est donc le rendez vous
c'est le conseil européen de décembre et
nous aurons à ce moment là
collectivement les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement à prendre les conséquences
et de la situation actuelle et de
l'attitude turque pour parler très
concrètement là des actes que nous
attendons la turquie c'est le retrait
des mercenaires syrien déployés à ses
frais à son instigation dans le haut
karabakh
ça en fait partie et puisque vous m'avez
interrogé monsieur le président à propos
du haut karabagh je voudrais vous dire
quelques faire quelques remarques
d'abord pour vous dire que l'arrêt des
combats étaient indispensables mais
l'arrêt des combats n'a pas résolu de
manière durable cette crise et il
n'apporte pas non plus de réponse à la
crise humanitaire qui touche l'arménie
il y a donc trois priorités d'action
pour la france d'abord jouer notre rôle
de co président de ce qu'on appelle le
groupe de minsk
alors le groupe de minsk était
responsabilité à 3
la russie les etats-unis et la france
décidée après un premier conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
ces trois pays ont la responsabilité de
la mise en oeuvre de négociations au
mois du respect du cessez-le-feu de
l'époque et donc dans ce qu est un
gâteau et donc nous faisons nous avons
donc à jouer tout notre rôle pour faire
en sorte que les paramètres de cet
accord puisse être clarifiées et qu' il
puisse y avoir un processus de
discussion qui se met en oeuvre et donc
il ya des angles morts dans cet accord
qui nécessitent des garanties je pense à
eux au départ des combattants étrangers
je viens d'en parler je pense au retour
des personnes déplacées essentiellement
d'ailleurs beaucoup des arméniens qui
devront revenir dans le haut karabakh et
je pense aussi à la protection du
patrimoine historique et culturel et
donc poursuivre les discussions avec
l'ensemble des partis pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse clarifier tout
cela y compris avec la russie mais je
m'entretiens très régulièrement avec mon
collègue lavrov sur ce sujet y compris
auprès des états unis y compris même
avec la président sortant des etats unis
puisque cette question a été abordée
lors des entretiens que j'ai pu avoir
avec monsieur pompéo la semaine dernière
quand il n'est passé à paris il ya par
ailleurs la nécessité de renforcer notre
solidarité humanitaire avec l'arménie
c'est une action tout à fait
déterminante
nous avons engagé
première livraison dimanche dernier avec
un avion gros porteur qui affrétait qui
plusieurs dizaines de tonnes de matériel
vers erevan il ya un autre vol qui
partira demain après demain avec aussi
une aide de l'état français mais aussi
d'associations de collectivités locales
que nous coordonnons dans un comité de
pilotage qui rassemble l'état les ong et
des associations de la communauté
arménienne de france et il importe
essentiellement d'ailleurs de soutenir
le secteur de santé les hôpitaux
arméniens mais aussi d'aider à au retour
des déplacés sur leur lieu de vie et
puis il faut que nous passions un cessez
le feu militaire aussi un cessez-le-feu
culturel en mettant en place rapidement
des conditions de préservation du
patrimoine c'est ce que nous faisons en
mobilisant une institution qui a été
créé il ya 4 ou 5 ans qui s'appelle
l'alliance pour la protection du
patrimoine dans les zones de conflits
qu'on appelle généralement la leaf qui
est présidée par me souvienne et qui
aussi un partenariat important avec les
émirats arabes unis la france et
quelques autres pays pour permettre à la
foi d'expertisés l'état du patrimoine et
d'engager les structures les
consolidations les réhabilitations
nécessaire dans cette région qui à un
patrimoine culturel et religieux
considérable nous travaillons sur ces
bases là et
pour répondre aux demandes des clients
supplémentaires mais c'est de l'état
d'esprit et qui nous anime en ce moment
sommes en relation permanente avec les
autorités arméniennes je vais recevoir
mon collègue arméniens dans les semaines
prochaines
nouveaux collègues ce qui est quelques
difficultés politiques en arménie pour
pouvoir aboutir à la mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble de ces paramètres et nous
sommes dans le trio des coprésidents
tout à fait en phase pour aller danser
les danses et de direction avec les
précautions indispensables mais je pense
que nous avons sont de manière positive
voilà pour quelques urgences du moment
je vous avais vous m'avez interrogé sur
aussi sur les relations nouvelles que
nous pourrions avoir avec la nouvelle
administration américaine a d'abord
j'observe que le président trump
président sortant a autorisé la mise en
oeuvre de relation directe avec le
président l'équipe du président entrant
c'est une bonne chose et nous avons avec
la nouvelle administration américaine à
construire une nouvelle relation
transatlantique
je voudrais dire ici que je me réjouis
tout particulièrement de la désignation
par le président élu
de monsieur antony blinken comme
collègue futur même s'il reste il lui
reste à être validé par le congrès je
m'en réjouis d'autant plus fortement que
il se trouve que j'ai pu travailler avec
lui dans une vie antérieure sur un
centre de sujets liés aux enjeux de
défense pense que ce sera une nomination
qui permettra d'éclairer une relation
transatlantique qui en avaient besoin
avec le respect de l'autonomie de chacun
mais avec une méthode qui sera basée sur
le multilatéralisme puisqu'il en est
porteur de ces messages régulièrement
particulier sur les sujets cruciaux
il ya des sujets sur lequel on va
avancer assez vite parce que c'est ce
sur quoi vous m'interrogez monsieur le
président je pense que le fait que le
président élu et annoncé qu'il revenait
dans les accords de paris concernant le
climat va nous permettre de préparer de
manière active
la coop 26 de glasgow à la fin de
l'année prochaine dans une nouvelle
donne dans une nouvelle configuration
avec des exigences indispensables
je pense que nous aurons aussi sur les
questions de la santé des ouvertures
manifester puisque le président et lui
annoncer qu'il revenait dans le
dispositif de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
je pense que nous aurons aussi sur un
sujet d'urgence concernant le les
accords de vienne sur l'iran des
possibilités d'agir
assez assez rapidement on va rentrer
dans les discussions à partir de ces
trois sujets là et puis ira le reste la
redéfinition d'une relation
transatlantique
il faut il faut pas se leurrer
nous ne l'ont pas ferrand se faire en
sorte de revenir à ce que ça tu pointes
et il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
depuis quatre ans due à la présidence
américaine du président tram est dû
aussi à l'évolution du monde des
rapports de force sont beaucoup aggraver
les conflits tu alité se sont manifestés
des enjeux nouveaux sont apparus
l'affirmation de la chine d'en haut
niveau de internationale mais en même
temps une une brutalité des rapports qui
s'est mise en oeuvre bref ne sommes plus
dans le même monde et donc il va falloir
chercher à refonder un équilibre parce
qu'aussi pendant ce temps là je crois
qu'on peut dire que l'europe s'est
affirmé que les sorties de la naïveté
même s'il ya encore quelques pans de la
ftc lequel il faut agir la jada de
souveraineté de
de l'europe et l'agenda de refondation
de la relation transatlantique ont
vocation à former un cercle vertueux il
n'ya pas raison de les opposer mais il
n'y a pas non plus raison de même d'être
timide sur nos évolutions et et nos
exigences dans cet esprit là que nous
allons aborder la nouvelle relation avec
nos
la nouvelle équipe américaine et dans ce
paquet il y aura aussi à consolider
l'alliance atlantique qui était un peu
perturbé par des actions et des
déclarations qui ont pu éventuellement
les remettre en cause la solidité de
l'alliance comme le président la
république avait eu l'occasion de le
dire avec beaucoup de force il fallait
réfléchir aux enjeux stratégiques de
l'otan et c'est à la suite de ses
déclarations qu'un groupe de travail sur
l'avenir de l'otan étaient mises en
place il va rendre ses conclusions
maintenant rapidement lors de la
prochaine réunion de mise affaires
étrangères de l'otan qui va avoir lieu
la semaine prochaine et donc à partir de
là on aura des éléments pour envisager
avec les états unis d'amérique une
nouvelle relation plus équilibrée jeu
lille il faut qu'elle soit plus
sécurisée partout y compris dans le
cadre de l'otan je crois que si
l'intérêt des états unis d'avoir une
europe forte d'avoir un allié fort
plutôt que d'avoir un partenaire faible
est essentiellement aux ordres donc
dans cette logique là que nous allons
travailler dans les jours qui viennent
une fois que la nouvelle équipe sera
installée mais il faut attendre pour
cela le 20 janvier parce que la position
américaine de la nouvelle équipe et les
justes les de dire il y a qu un seul
président à la fois aux états unis donc
il faut attendre que le nouveau
président soit vraiment installée pour
pouvoir engager des discussions sur les
sujets que je viens d'évoquer
il nous restera aussi à reparler avec
des américains de plusieurs sujets
compliqués que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure et que nous avons évoqué
ensemble ici il ya pas mal à plusieurs
reprises y compris la question turque y
compris la question libyenne y compris
la question irakienne et la question de
dèche
voilà mesdames et monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
quelques propos rappelons peut-être
enfin essentiel je crois un mot sur la
réforme du franc cfa puisque vous l'avez
rappelé l'assemblée nationale examinera
le projet d'accord de coopération
monétaire entre la france et de l'union
économique et monétaire des états
d'afrique de l'ouest le 10 décembre
prochain
cette réforme qui remplace l'accord de
73 répond à une demande des pays
concernés c'est un vraiment un acte
nouveau moderniser et renouvelée des
coopération monétaire avec la france et
entre la france et les pays de l'ue
devra il ya un changement de nom même si
le nom encore il ya encore de
discussions au sein de ces héros pour
retenir les commerçants n'ont cessé de
la responsabilité des acteurs de le
définir la fin de la centralisation des
réserves de changes de la banque
centrale des états d'afrique de l'ouest
auprès du trésor français le retrait de
la france des instances de gouvernance
mais par ailleurs le choix du maintien
d'une parité fixe avec de l'euro qui a
été décidé par les chefs d'état de
l'uemoa
ces deux réformes est une étape
importante qu'on est conforme d'ailleurs
aux orientations qu'avait donné le
président de la république dans son
discours de ouagadougou et elle
intervient aussi à un moment où les
africains eux mêmes sont en train de
mettre en place sur l'ensemble de
l'afrique une zone de libre-échange
continentale africaine
ce n'est pas le même sujet mais c'est
des sujets qui sont articulés et qui
sont tout à fait essentiel pour avoir
une relation et d'un véritable
partenariat entre l'europe et l'afrique
et la fin du franc cfa a évidemment une
très forte valeur symbolique
à cet égard voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en ouverture monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs merci monsieur le
ministre pour ce propos liminaire très
éclairant pour nous tous parce que je
crois que on a eu tous les sujets jeu
maintenant passer la parole aux orateurs
de groupes pour la république en marche
binh thanh
je crois qu'il rend vision mais la liste
ne sais pas oui on entend pas oui très
bien merci merci président monsieur le
ministre aux épinards riches sont tous
très heureux de vous accueillir
l'assemblée nationale et je vous prie de
m'excuser de ne pas être à vos côtés
physiquement et si j'ai abordé à avoir
d'aujourd'hui sont nombreux et nous
permettront de faire le point sur
l'actualité internationale
je laisserai donc le soin mes collègues
de compléter mon intervention a eu leurs
questions à propos portera sur
l'actualité de la kz1 de pacifique
une semaine après la signature de
partenariat régional et économique
globale
r c'est loupé ce partenariat constitue à
ce jour le plus important accord
commercial au monde et d'essayer par la
chine le japon la corée du sud
l'australie la nouvelle-zélande et les
dix pays membres de la grc 15 pays
représentent à eux seuls 2 milliards de
consommateurs sont environ 30% de la
population mondiale 30 % du pib mondial
et pas loin de 30 % des échanges
internationaux
cet accord porte à c'est essentiellement
ce ne baisse des droits de douane de 80
% de produits échangés
or bien que l'école est ce une
simplification des démarches
administratives liées aux transactions
commerciales odeur de son importance
économique
ce partenariat une forte valeur
symbolique tout d'abord parce que les
etats unis soient absents c'est qu'il ne
fait que renforcer le poids de la chine
mais également car c'est le premier
accord commercial signé entre corée du
sud le japon et la chine la chine
apparaît incontestablement comme la
grande gagnante de cette signature
en s'imposant comme la grotte la garante
du multilatéralisme
elle renforce son influence dans cette
région selon les premières estimations
elle serait le premier bénéficiaire cet
accord avec un surplus de revenus de
près de 85 milliards de dollars à
l'horizon 2030
fort de cette hégémonie chinoise
emmanuel face pendant la cdm et
hégémonie chinoise et moi ne me croira
appelé dès 2018 à nouvel ordre
géostratégique en refusant
être associé directement ou quoi
dialogues aux intérêts de notre japon
l'un des états unis que votre avis la
france promet une position d'équilibré
entre les etats-unis et la chine ainsi
que sa vision du multilatéralisme
le président l'a rappelé la kz1 de
pacifique constitue l'un des grands
enjeux de demain
et la france s'est ralliée cette région
non seulement en tant que puissance
étrangère mais en tant que puissance
voisine car ce sont bien plus de 1
million 600 mille de nos concitoyens qui
vivent dans cette zone économique
exclusive française dont plus de 90% de
ses neuf minogue kilomètres carrés
située dans le pacifique et l'océan
indien
la présence militaire de la france est
également important dans cette région le
dispositif actuel qui s'était dit
gauthier à la polynésie on prend cinq
commandements régionaux trois bases et
quelques 7000 militaires
si la france entend s'imposer comme les
puissances militaires à cette région le
président la république a rappelé est là
également il renforcer ses partenariats
économiques technologiques et
stratégiques tracé ma question porte aux
trois aspects la signature d'hier s'est
opérée métal en cause la stratégie de la
france dans la crise pacifique
ensuite quelle sera la politique de la
france pour parvenir à s'imposer face
aux différentes puissances asiatiques
tout en continuant à regarder son
indépendance vis-à-vis de la chine et
les états unis et enfin actuellement
isolé au sein de l'europe
cela fait un don pacifique la france a
des propositions de ravir s'impose
s'intéresser aux européens afin de
renforcer la position de l'europe dans
la région
je vous remercie vous admire aux
réponses merci beaucoup chers collègues
pour les républicains michel herbillon
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
merci de votre tour d'horizon qui est
pour nous toujours intéressant je
voudrais revenir sur ce que vous avez
évoqué à propos des relations avec la
turquie
je tiens à souligner vos propos qui sont
extrêmement claires je rappelle que ya
la présence de la turquie sur un nom
important de théâtre d'opérations vous
l'avais dit en irak en libye en syrie en
méditerranée orientale et et je veux
aussi condamné nous l'avons tous et
mechtel rhodia les propos parfaitement
inacceptable et scandaleux du président
erdogan à l'égard du président la
république emmanuel macron le fait que
ses pairs de gan a pris la tête d'une
fronde contre la france en lançant un
mouvement de boycott des produits
français et vous avez à juste titre
manifester l'opposition de la france à
la politique de fait accompli de la
turquie et à sa volonté expansionniste
alors vous avez indiqué que vous
attendiez des actes de la part de recep
tayyip erdogan
parmi ces actes parmi ces actes vous
avez évoqué à l'instant le retrait des
mercenaires syrien dans le haut karabakh
vous avez indiqué que cette question des
relations avec la turquie concernés
l'europe toute entière et que salle est
un des sujets du conseil européen de
décembre
alors au delà de l'es2 du retrait des
mercenaires syrien dans le haut-karabakh
que vous avez évoqué je voudrais vous
demander quels sont les autres actes que
vous attendez de la part de erdogan
quels sont à ce stade nous sommes
quelques quelques jours du prochain
conseil européen donc tout ça se prépare
qu'attendez vous du prochain conseil
européen par rapport aux relations avec
la turquie
et est ce que leur examen avec nos
partenaires européens du processus
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne
est ce que ceci fait partie des actes
concrets que vous attendez de la part du
conseil 21 et est ce que la france va
prendre une position très claire
vis-à-vis de ce processus d'adhésion qui
a été ouvert il ya très longtemps qui si
j'ose dire n'en finit pas de finir et
qui se situe aujourd'hui dans des
conditions extrêmement différente de
celle où du moment où ces négociations
ont commencé
ça c'est ma première question est
importante et la seconde question
puisque on s'approche à un mois près de
la fin de la présidence allemande
vous avez vos pieds à juste titre un
certain nombre de sujets qui ont été
traités par cette présidence allemande
quel bilan vous tirer cette présidence
allemande et qu'attendez-vous du de la
prochaine présidence qui va démarrer au
mois de janvier
je vous remercie merci beaucoup chers
collègues pour le mouvement démocrate
est démocrate apparenté bruno joncour
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur le ministre
merci de votre présence et de votre
analyse sur la situation internationale
vous avez rappelé quelques unes des
échéances qui s'impose à la france et au
monde dans les semaines et les mois à
venir énumérées comme cela et pourrait
paraître presque insurmontable donc
elles sont nombreuses profonde et
complexe mais elle s'impose à nous et
nous contraignent collectivement à
trouver les moyens d'une action
concertée commune d'ampleur il
nécessitera de la volonté de la part de
toutes les parties prenantes
on a trop tôt annoncé la mort de
multilatéralisme dans le règlement des
différends du monde sans voir que les
replis à l'image du royaume uni où des
états unis pouvait n'être que des
épiphénomènes traduisant changement
d'époque nous vivons la parenthèse d'une
géopolitique des états semble s'achever
celle d'une géopolitique des sociétés
civiles m'apparaît s'ouvrir dans cet
entre-deux il reste que certains états
semble s'affranchir de leurs engagements
internationaux pour nous
et que de la force brute fatah face à
eux les états démocratiques doivent
composer avec de multiples facteurs et
les exemples ne manquent pas pourtant
que ce soit la situation sanitaire
internationale celle du terrorisme
celle des conflits gelés de l'urgence
climatique
rien de tout cela ne peut trouver de
faim acceptable sans la promotion d'un
nouveau mode de concertation
multilatérale qui englobe non seulement
les considérations politiques mais aussi
les aspects économiques sociaux et
sécuritaires des signes encourageants se
décide entre uction peu à peu d'une voie
européenne changements récents de
l'administration des états unis l'échec
des populismes à répondre à ses attentes
dans ce contexte les outils de du
multilatéralisme internationale doivent
pas le moindre pensée c'est l'action de
la france depuis plusieurs années sous
votre impulsion monsieur le ministre
c'est aussi l'occasion de multiplier les
initiatives qui mettent en lien les
sociétés civiles au delà des états qui
en sont les acteurs traditionnels et à
cet égard le sommet des deux rives et à
l'exemple cette configuration me semble
porteuse d'espoir pour l'avenir sur le
ministre l'environnement international
nous oblige à repenser durablement notre
approche géopolitique et permet
d'entrevoir nouvelles perspectives à
cette collaboration nécessaire autour de
nouveaux modes d'action qui ne seraient
plus uniquement de l'ordre de la
confrontation des puissances dans cette
perspective elle pourrait en être selon
vous les futurs marqueur et comment la
france pourra faciliter plus encore son
émergence
j'avais un deuxième point mais vous y
avez fait allusion et vous avez répondu
dans votre propos liminaire il
s'agissait de l'état des négociations
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne notamment pour ce qui
concerne
la pêche à l'approché de la clôture des
négociations l'incertitude suscite tout
beaucoup d'inquiétude vous le savez
évidemment de la part du monde de la
pêche et je voulais savoir s'il y avait
des avancées récentes
al'approche de l'issue de ces
négociations mais aussi avait répondu à
l'instant merci monsieur le ministre
encore une fois pour ne pas que le
ministre puisse plus pour répondre je
vous demanderais vraiment d'être
vraiment considéré aux questions alors
pour les socialistes et apparentés
christian hutin
oui merci monsieur le président je vous
ai dit tout n'est pas au nom du groupe
j'aimerais un sentiment plus personnel
je mise d'abord merci de votre venue et
merci de vos explications
je vais parler un peu du fond il ya
quelque chose comme ça qui me gêne mais
ça correspond à tous les sujets que nous
avons abordés durant l'ensemble de votre
propos et je dis très je suis un homme
de gauche je suis un souverainiste
chevènementiste mai et pour moi les
nationalismes c'est la peste de la
nation mais la nation c'est quelque
chose d'important et le président de la
république il fait de plus en plus
référence depuis un certain nombre de
ses discours
or durant vos propos
intéressant et vous avez employé
exactement où à peu près trente neuf
fois le mot europe ou aux européens et
trois fois le mot france alors que vous
savez ministre de l'europe je le conçois
en priorité ministre des affaires
étrangères de la france en 2d mais il ne
faudrait pas que ça porte le flanc à
d'autres nationalisme alors c'est pas du
tout un reproche mais tout tout les
toutous ce propos est lié à une voie là
il ya un autre nationaliste que le mien
que de ceux de ceux du président de la
république et ses examens d exemple je
vais être très court sur les fonds
propres
l'initiative oms ou serait ce serait
honteux de le nier elle est au président
macron je le pense au départ sur le
l'idée de générer un plan de relance
européen et je pense pas qu'on puisse
lui retirer sa peut-être avec madame
merkel mais mais je pense qu'on en
personne pour aller retirer ça mais on
est bloqué à nouveau par rapport à cette
idée que notre nation se fait qu'un
certain nombre de pays européens se font
de la lumière de 2,2 des libertés de
l'indépendance de la justice de sa tombe
de liberté pour les femmes qui ne sont
plus en réel dans un certain nombre de
pays qui font pourtant partie de cette
europe qu'on loue est en nous et on
rejoue ce qu'on appelle des pays frugaux
je vois pourquoi ces frugaux ce que
c'est vraiment une appellation
complètement ridicule mais mais voilà ça
c'est la première chose et donc c'est
déjà c'est un point ça c'est un point
qui est important de l'action de la
france par rapport à son lead et que la
damnation d'un public laïcité etc est
bloquée par des pays en europe le break
6 c'est pareil le bac si c'est la france
qui est concerné aujourd'hui
essentiellement la corse ne vais pas
essentiellement à cause de la pêche en
grande partie et la pêche c'est quoi
c'est ce sont les hauts de france en
libye comparer c'est un peu la belgique
- parce qu'ils se débrouillent il passe
par le nord est puis se débrouille avec
les avec les hollandais mais c'est
essentiellement et et chez vous aussi ça
jusqu'à chez vous absolument et la
bretagne est alors de 2 dunkerque eux
n'ont pas tabane racette mais bon la
mémé de dunkerque eux
jusqu'au bout de la bretagne vous voulez
mais le la mais s'associe la france et
c'est pas l'europe qui va nous aider sur
les quotas de pêche ça y'a aucun danger
dans la mesure où le zoo sur tous nos
hôtes dunkerquoise calaisienne
boulonnaise sont pillées par les
hollandais avec la pêche électrique avec
des nouvelles donc là on n'est pas dans
l'europe
on est dans là on est en guerre contre
un certain nombre de pays d'europe en
guerre de la pêche et le troisième point
c'est la turquie je pense que il ne faut
pas attendre parce que nous sommes nous
ciblés par la turquie j'avais fait une
mission par nsai mais combien de
missions en turquie c'est la france qui
est beaucoup plus ciblé que beaucoup
d'autres et l'allemagne a une position
qui est plus ambigu continue de son
histoire et continue de 2,2 de sa
population donc attendre que les copains
viennent en disant retenez moi sinon je
fais un malheur
je ne pense pas que ce soit une solution
qui soit audible pour un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens
à un moment la france va dire voilà on
peut s'appuyer sur l'europe mais ne
comptons pas con que sur l'europe
voilà merci beaucoup et je penserai est
resté courtois je suis sorti un peu du
sujet mais je tenais à exprimer ce point
de vue qui est assez rare dans cette
commission
merci beaucoup chers collègues pour agir
ensemble
mjid el guerrab merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre le cessez
le feu conclu entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan le 9 novembre dernier sous
l'égide de la russie à la suite d'un
conflit de plusieurs jours n'est que
nouvel épisode
une rivalité ancienne qui oppose
arménien et azerbaïdjanais
alors que tous les regards se portent et
à juste titre sur l' influence turque
dans le conflit
une nouvelle fois c'est la russie qui a
tiré son épingle du jeu
on a en abritant des conditions du
cessez-le-feu par ailleurs il nous faut
garder à l'esprit mutuelle ministres que
la france et l'azerbaïdjan entretiennent
des relations très anciennes la
coopération universitaire est un axe
important
la coopération culturelle franco
azerbaïdjanaise dont l'université franco
azerbaijan est situé à bas coûts est
inaugurée en septembre 2016 constitue le
plus bel exemple de cette relation
d'amitié et de confiance
mais encore la coopération scientifique
et de recherche entre la
l'azerbaïdjan s'est développé également
par le biais de l'antenne de l'institut
français d'études anatoliennes quitté
qui est importé à bas coûts depuis 2002
en effet comme dans l'ensemble du
caucase des high desert herbages dzair
vague belge année pardon sont
francophones aux entreprises françaises
installées dans le pays la france se
positionne par ailleurs comme le
septième investisseur étranger dans le
pays faisant ainsi du pays
notre premier partenaire économique du
sud-caucase devant l'arménie et la
géorgie
en outre un institut français est
implanté depuis 2004 à bakou où un lycée
français financé et géré par la mission
laïque française a également commencé à
fonctionner en 2013 près d'une trentaine
d'accords aptères universitaire lit des
établissements publics d'enseignement
azerbaïdjanais ad on a des universités
françaises
l'azerbaïdjan est par ailleurs un peuple
ancien qui ont une vraie culture du
vivre ensemble de nombreuses et nino
nazeri les idées talich les havas les
russes des pâtes à des juifs etc
vive en azerbaïdjan en parfaite harmonie
dans le respect et où chacun peut
pratiquer sa foi sans être inquiété
l'azerbaïdjan est un pays profondément
laïque
c'est d'ailleurs le premier pays laïc du
monde musulman
et c'est peut-être le seul pays au monde
où cohabitent pacifiquement
autant de religion cela a été popularisé
par alexandre dumas et georges centre et
qui inquiets en 1843 était la première à
traduire en français l'épopée
azerbaïdjanaise de korhogo en f
enfin au delà de ces considérations la
reconnaissance unilatérale du haut
karabakh comme le souhaite le sénat
pourrait être dangereuse pour la
position de la france dans le monde
alors que d'autres territoires dans le
caucase comme le ceti du sud où la brazy
pourrait en demander autant la france a
ainsi voté à quatre reprises pour les
résolutions du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu adoptée en 1993 en avril en
juillet en octobre et en novembre qui
prévoit le respect de la souveraineté de
l'intégrité territoriale et de
l'inviolabilité des frontières
internationalement reconnues de la
république d azerbaïdjan sans ingérence
aucune dette anciens important pour
notre pays d'avoir une vision équilibrée
et pondéré de ce conflit donc ma
question monsieur ministre des
résolutions d'émotion
locales ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'initiatives pourrait être adopté par
l'assemblée nationale le sénat où la
mairie de paris ne conviennent contre
vient-elle pas au statut de médiateurs
de la france monsieur le ministre
quelle est la position officielle de la
france sur toutes ces résolutions et ses
initiatives locales
le gouvernement va-t-il donner un avis
favorable à ces textes
ainsi monsieur le ministre n'y at il pas
urgence pour la france a conservé sa
neutralité à même de lui assurer sa
présence aux deux ministres
merci merci chers collègues je rappelle
vraiment à tous les collègues parce que
si nous voulons que tout le monde puisse
poser des questions miss avant qu'ils
partent
je vous demande vraiment d'être concis
dans l'est dans vos questions parce que
sinon voilà c'est ce serait dommage pour
les autres voilà alors pour pour udi et
indépendant meyer habib ans
est-ce que vous m'entendez voilà ça doit
aller là je m'entendais l' ambitieux oui
très bien c'est très bien oui chers
collègues tu peux l epad en désole le
sous ministre
merci pour votre propos liminaire merci
d'avoir parlé de la turquie j'oublie
justement revenir un petit peu là dessus
dans un premier temps j'ai interrogé le
gouvernement le 27 octobre dernier sur
les provocations les agressions les
humiliations du président de la
république du président les d'organes de
nouveau sultan d'ankara je parle pas
évidemment de la grèce de la chypre avec
des conflits du chantage migratoire etc
etc
le ministre de l'intérieur m'avait
répondu dans son domaine de compétences
c'est-à-dire à savoir l'entrisme
d'ankara en islam de france
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre propos
liminaire à la veille du conseil
européen
vous avez clairement dit que les
déclarations leader turc ne suffirait
pas dont acte
ma première question je ne pense que
d'abord on comprend que le rapport de
forces est ce qu'il y aura réellement
des sanctions dissuasives
est ce qu'il y a t-il un consiste
consensus européen j'ai écouté avec
attention mon ami hutin développer ses
arguments sur l'importance de prendre le
leadership et que la france décide sur
cette question mais j'arrive à mon point
de vue féministe le 11 novembre nous
français nous avons une somme d'associer
lors de l'assemblée générale de l'om
est-ce à une résolution qui condamne et
israël pour des violations des droits la
santé des palestiniens c'est une
révolution mensongère parce que vous
savez très bien que tous les
palestiniens à ce qu'on soigner et c'est
tout à fait bien dans les hôpitaux
israéliens comme il sait manier le
leader du tram as ou sa libairie 4
est mort hélas pour les palestiniens
dans un hôpital il serait bien là il ya
deux semaines donc c'est une résolution
mensongères et qui était portée partie
par la turquie d'erdogan et aussi par
par la grande démocratie que la syrie
d'assad et par l'auto parler signal est
ce que vous croyez franchement monsieur
le ministre que cette bonne résolution
turc mensongère et diffamatoire
ce soit de nature à renforcer notre
crédibilité dans le bras de fer qui les
oppose à au président est légale et si
la france a décidé de voter cette
résolution de s'associer à cette
religion honteuse de l' oms
comment expliquez vous monsieur ménisque
eu un silence du quai d'orsay alors
qu'on a vu la rue palestinienne dehors
en train de hurler du brûlé les
portraits du président de la république
premier mort à la france devant la
résidence de leur ambassadeur à tel-aviv
devant l'ambassade doter la ville devant
le mont du temple à jérusalem et je
pense que j'ai pas écouté de
condamnation par contre on continue à
condamner régulièrement la construction
de n'importe quels logements en judée la
samarie alors que pompéo le ministre
sortant américain s'est rendu dans le
golan s'est rendu dans une implantation
juive de samarie je sais que c'est à la
position de la france est d'être une
paix qui est en train de se faire dans
cette région communiste italien ou a vu
le peu le nbs enfin c'est pas confirmé
mais il semblerait que ça a eu lieu il
ya une paix qui est en train de se faire
avec le soudan avec et nous j'ai
l'impression qu'on a je vous dis
amicalement mais franchement monsieur le
ministre ce que vous êtes en charge de
notre diplomatie
on a appelé un logiciel qui est périmé
qu'il faut changer pour pas qu'on voie
intra passer un train la paix et voir
des pays comme la turquie comme l'iran
d'un côté et tous les autres prix y aura
beaucoup de pays sunnites changé et
comprendre aujourd'hui que les choses
ont changé c'est tellement important
puis voilà je voulais terminer parce que
peut pas être trop long on pas les
livres en bon livre en évidemment je
connais la position donc j'ai votre
position personnelle c'est l'accord mais
j'ai votre le porte parole allemand
disait tout récemment des affaires
étrangères que l'iran n'a pas arrêté la
parité de violer
de violer l'accord il se dirige vers le
nucléaire c'est une immense inquiétude
pour le monde le monde libre de savoir
qu'un état islamiste pourrait avoir une
bombe nucléaire
celui-ci est opposé je voulais merci
beaucoup chers collègues pour le groupe
liberté et territoires frédéric dumas ya
pas le sang en tentant pas frédéric
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre alassane ouattara
côte d'ivoire alpha condé en guinée
tous deux ont suivi un processus
strictement identiques troisième mandat
anticonstitutionnel résultats non
crédibles attestation arrestations
d'opposants violence avec morts et
blessés le président de la république a
pourtant félicité alassane ouattara pour
son élection le président réduit en dix
ans d'ailleurs donc le présent à redon
réduit ainsi le débat une histoire de
personnes par deux personnalités
l'un l'une une personnalité aurait violé
la constitution effectivement alpha
condé alassane ouattara ne l'aurais pas
fait de son côté de votre côté monsieur
le ministre
au terme d'un séjour de 24 heures au
niger vous avez rendu un vibrant hommage
au président issoufou qui arrivait en
fin de mandat respecte son engagement de
ne pas se représenter pour un troisième
mandat
mais ce ministre d'aller déclarer je
suis venu pour rencontrer président
issoufou avant la fin de son mandat ici
parce que nous avons depuis 2012 de
nombreux échanges de qualité je tenais à
lui rendre hommage
il s'agit donc bien d'un soutien affiché
en pleine campagne électorale
vous allez d'ailleurs déclaré à propos
des élections de décembre elles vont
avoir lieu au moment où elles doivent
avoir dans le respect de la constitution
la qualité de l'élection du niger sera
une référence pour toute l'afrique
mais je fais à personne que vous avez
tenu ces propos sur l'exemplarité du
résultat de ces élections avant même que
c'est la sélection et mieux vous avez
tenu ces propos monsieur nice alors même
que la candidature du principal opposant
au président et souffre d'être invalidée
par la cour constitutionnelle sur des
bases puisque discutable et alors qu'il
terminait une tournée dans tout pays est
rempli cette escalade
alors messieurs ministre vous normal que
le président de la finance puissent
féliciter un président d'un autre pays
pour sa réélection alors que cette
dernière s'est faite au mépris de la
constitution
trouvez vous normal monsieur le ministre
que le président de la france puisse
distribuer des bons points en fonction
de son intérêt du moment trouvez vous
normal pour votre part monsieur min
félicitez un président pour
l'exemplarité du déroulement des
élections alors qu'elles n'ont pas
encore eu lieu pensez vous que le seul
fait que ces élections aient lieu dans
le soi-disant respect de la constitution
suffisent à rendre cette élection
exemplaire
ne pensez vous pas que ces comportements
et ses propos risquent d'embraser une
partie d'afrique notamment de sahel que
vous serez alors amené a déploré les
conséquences de vos propres actes sur la
turquie ils je voulais vraiment
intervenir après avoir entendu vos
propos et les propos de certains de mes
collègues il ya des divergences réelles
au fond nous faut affronter avec ce pays
et je pense que les propos que vous
tenez sont heureux ne reflète pas
vraiment la réalité je suis poli on dire
dans ça en disant ça et je pense que
c'est important de le faire puisque
justement nos pays nos deux pays mérite
beaucoup mieux et je voulais justement
parlé notamment un exemple de l'accord
migratoire dont certains parlent de
chantage libre à toi cet accord
migratoire
il ya trois millions et demi de réfugiés
en turquie 6 en langue kurde 600
naissances depuis
est-ce que nous avons respecté les
contreparties et vous savez que dolan
dans les contreparties lille adéquat il
y avait effectivement une enveloppe
financière comme ça moi d'avoir
évidemment respecter nous avons donné
l'équivalent en quatre ans de ce que
nous aurions donné en un an mais il y
avait aussi le fait de rediscuter de
l'adhésion de la turquie
il y avait des visas pour la circulation
des turcs y avait le fait d'aider
effectivement aussi les turcs à ce que
des réfugiés puissent revenir en syrie
tout ça nous l'avons pas respectée dans
la même chose avec l'iran demandant à
l'iran de respecter de son côté ses
engagements sans jamais que nous
respectueux et nous demandons donc à
tous ces pays de respecter des
engagements que de notre côté c'est pas
que nous ne respectons pas nous ne
respectons aucun je vous remercie dieu
merci beaucoup chers collègues pour la
gauche démocrate et républicaine jean
paul lecoq
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le vendredi 13 novembre
l'attaqué perpétrée par le maroc sur le
territoire du sahara occidental à la
fois en zone occupée et aux zones libres
à l'encontre des manifestants sahraouis
a marqué la fin du cessez-le-feu en
vigueur depuis 1900
91 entres les forces marocaines et le
front polisario cela s'est passé à
guérir at lieu-dit à côté d'une brèche
illégales versées par le maroc dans le
mur qui sépare le sahara occidental
occupé de la mauritanie et qui permet au
maroc de commencer de commercer avec
l'afrique subsaharienne
cette brèche illégal c'est une insulte
aux accords de cessez-le-feu qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû être maintenues
ouvertes et les sahraouis ont été
patients et ils ont demandé depuis près
de 30 ans que cette situation cesse sans
avoir jamais été écoutés la france en
tant que membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies est
responsable de cette situation parce que
jamais les obligations du maroc n'ont
été mises en oeuvre
lorsque ce pays a été condamné pour
avoir torturé des prisonniers politiques
sahraouis par le comité contre la
torture de l'onu
parce que jamais la mission la mission
de des nations unies au sahara
occidental la minurso n'a englober la
surveillance des droits de l'homme c'est
d'ailleurs la seule mission de l'onu à
ne pas avoir cette prérogative
opposition de la france parce que jamais
le référendum d'autodétermination n'a
été mis en place
parce que jamais la brèche de guergarat
tu n'as été refermés par la minurso
responsabilité ensuite en tant que
membre de l'union européenne qui a mis
en place un accord commercial avec le
maroc incluant des produits commerce des
produits commerciaux du sahara
occidental en toute illégalité violent
l'interdiction du pillage des ressources
de ce territoire non autonome et
d'ailleurs des condamnations eu lieu
responsabilité ensuite au titre de
partenaire du maroc puisque vous
indiquer que le plan d'autonomie
marocain est une base crédible de
négociations alors que ce plan viole le
droit international
c'est une prise de position totalement
en soutien au maroc
l'amitié franco-marocaine que je
souhaite sincèrement ne doit pas vous
aveugler vous ne devez pas vous limiter
aux seules options que propose la
diplomatie marocaine ni épouse et ses
intérêts dans cette zone être franc en
amitié c'est la base de la confiance
mutuelle non vous savez bien que
l'immobilisme diplomatique favorise la
colonisation de peuplement en faveur du
maroc et en même temps produits les
germes de reprise de la guerre parce que
comme pour la palestine comme pour la
rate le statu quo favorise l'occupant et
comme pour l'arménie le ca du coup
favorise la guerre l'immobilisme du
conseil de sécurité à cause
de l'attitude de la france est coupable
d'avoir laissé tomber depuis 45 ans le
peuple sahraoui le multilatéralisme
c'est le droit international
rien que le droit international et tous
le droit international alors monsieur le
ministre au nom de l'amitié
franco-marocaine allez vous enfin
choisir le chemin du droit international
pour la résolution de ce conflit
allez-vous faire en sorte qu'une sortie
de crise soit envisagée sous la
surveillance du conseil de sécurité en
instaurant ce référendum
d'autodétermination promis depuis 1991
et s'il fallait poursuivre
l'argumentation sachez que les
ressources le phosphate le poisson les
marchés publics le tourisme les
ressources économiques du sahara
occidental qui sont nombreuses attire
les entreprises étrangères dont les
entreprises françaises mais le sahara
occidental est un territoire statut
juridique particulier et le droit pénal
français pourrait contrarier les
stratégies des acteurs privés article 4
161 26 du code pénal qui réprime
sévèrement le crime de colonisation par
peuple mots ce travail vise à définir si
des entreprises transnationales
françaises peuvent être coupables de ce
crime
une question en effet pour retenir le
crime de colonisation par peuplement
pardon il faut qualifier le sahara
occidental le territoire a occupé ces
faits aient démontré que cette
occupation découle d'un conflit armé
international s'est fait et donc le défi
qui va nous nous occuper dans les
prochaines semaines et je termine là
dessus il s'agit de l'imputation de
crime aux entreprises
il s'agit de montrer en quoi des
activités d'entreprises françaises
pourraient constituer matériellement une
colonisation par peuplement ou
complicité de celle ci ce travail
juridique comme ans il a déjà porté ses
fruits et peut-être va-t-il enfin
éclairer la diplomatie française merci
beaucoup chers collègues
alors je vais maintenant de donner la
parole aux deux
rapporteur déjà à jean-françois bay en
tant que rapporteur sur le projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de l'accord
sous l'eau et moi et ensuite à pierre
alexandre anglet en tant que rapporteur
pressenti sur le projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de la décision
du conseil sur les ressources propres de
l'union européenne donc la parole est à
jean-françois merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre ce matin
à notre commission a examiné et adopté
l'accord de coopération entre le
gouvernement français et gouvernements
des états membres de l'union monétaire
ouest africaine qui vient donc refonder
l'accord monétaire de 1973 je rappelle
que de concert avec les autres états
membres de la communauté économique des
états de l'afrique de l'ouest la cedeao
les états non membres de la zone uemoa
avait été convenu que ceux-ci
organiserait en parallèle une
convergence macro économique durable et
vérifiable en leur sein dans le cadre
d'un deuxième regroupement monétaire
régionale dénommée la z mao la zone man
et monétaire de l'afrique de l'ouest
l'objectif étant à l'horizon à l'horizon
moyen et à long terme d'envisager la
fusion de ces deux zones monétaires
régionales dans la perspective de la
création d'une monnaie commune à
l'ensemble des 15 états membres de la
cedeao le nigeria à l'époque avait
d'ailleurs proposé de dénommer cette
monnaie commune
l'écolo appelé à évoluer en régime de
change flottant sans rattachement fixe à
quelconque devises étrangères à l'image
de la monnaie actuelle nigériane le
naira et c'est dans ce contexte que
l'accord monétaire que nous avons
examinés et adoptés en commission ce
matin est venu
cc les boss est arrivé pardon néanmoins
on l'a vue et lors de mes nombreux de
mes nombreuses auditions et de mes
déplacements
on a vu que tous les points d'étape
organisé de concert avec l'avènement
montre clairement une absence de progrès
vers la convergence macro économie ce
qui éloigne davantage cette perspective
de création d'une monnaie unique
couvrant à moyen terme l'ensemble de la
cedeao de ce sentiment il y à aussi dans
l'opinion publique une certaine forme de
je dirais de procès de procès
d'intention que l'on fait que l'on fait
à la france
j'ai aussi noté je les mentionnaient ce
matin dans mon rapport la possibilité de
créer un comité de réflexion sur les
contours de la future la future réforme
monétaire jeu j'ai évoqué la la question
d'associer le comité interparlementaire
de la zone uemoa
s'agissant de cette création de cette
future monnaie en question est toute
simple monsieur le ministre
au regard de tous ces éléments comment
est-ce que la france pourra engager une
réflexion avec les pays africains
comment elle pourra accompagner
l'esquissé d'un calendrier qui
comprendrait aussi la participation du
plus grand nombre c'est à dire des
parlements africains et notamment du
comité interparlementaire de la zone
uemoa
mais merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à pierre élections danglade
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
avec vous sur l'accord européen qui a
été scellée au mois de juillet dernier
accord historique avec 750 milliards
d'euros du plan de relance historique
d'abord par son ampleur parce que ce
plan est à même je crois d'éloigner le
risque d'implosion que cette crise
faisait courir à l'union européenne
historique par son financement parce que
pour la première fois de son histoire
l'union européenne va émettre une des
deux communes et historique enfin et
surtout par sa portée politique parce
qu'avec cet accord
je crois que les européens envoient un
message très fort au reste du monde nous
sommes unis et nous entendons le rester
pour les décennies à venir
et c'est la preuve que quand il ya de la
volonté de la détermination et bien on
peut faire bouger l'europe et certains
l'ont dit crois que nous devons cet
accord notamment à la volonté inlassable
du président de la république d'aller
vers une europe plus unie et plus
souveraine cette unité
cette unité et cette volonté européenne
elle s'est poursuivie avec l'accord
trouvé notamment avec le parlement
européen il ya de cela deux semaines
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé cet
accord est bloquée bloqué parce que deux
c'est à européen ou un en tout cas qui a
réussi en entraîner d'autres dans son
sillage haas a décidé de sacrifier en
tout cas temporairement l'intérêt
général européen sur l'autel d'intérêts
politiques nationaux et presque
partisans et donc je crois que ce plan
de relance qui doit bénéficier à 450
millions d'européens ne peut pas être
sacrifiés sur cet hôtel c'est à mon sens
inacceptable alors on nous dit que cet
accord pourrait être débloquée au sommet
européen de décembre
c'est une bonne chose et nous on le
souhaite évidemment ardemment dans cette
dans cette assemblée
mais je crois et pour faire et quoi
votre propos d'introduction que si
l'europe veut devenir une véritable
puissance entre les états unis
d'amérique et la chine elle ne peut pas
être sur courant alternatif
elle ne peut pas être
ala à la merci de la bonne volonté d'un
chef d'état qui décident d'imposer son
veto autrement nous ne sommes plus tout
à fait crédible et donc je crois que
notre europe ils méritent évidemment
mieux que cela a le mérite mieux que les
les blocages auxquels nous assistons est
que ce plan de relance il est absolument
indispensable si nous voulons que notre
économie se relève que nos entreprises
résistent au fond que notre continent
préparent l'avenir pour la décennie qui
s'ouvre est donc le parlement européen
l'a redit ce matin et un débat en séance
plénière
il ne reculera pas sur cet accord je
crois que notre groupe ici à l'assemblée
nationale est également prêt à avancer
donc on est évidemment impatient de
pouvoir être saisi sur ce texte donc
dans ce contexte nous attendons
évidemment que le conseil européen
prenne ses responsabilités et ma
conviction c'est que sur ce dossier
d'unanimité n'est pas la seule voie et
que si le blocage était amenée à durer
alors nous devrions avancer à 26 ou même
à 25
c'est évidemment pas la seule c'est pas
la solution que nous souhaiterions et je
pense que les montants engagés notamment
pour la pologne ou la hongrie elle
devrait permettre de débloquer cette
situation de guerre mais avoir votre
sentiment sur cette question je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup chers collègues avant de
passer à une autre sable question on va
laisser le monsieur le ministre répondre
à cette première série je vous cède la
parole michel me alors monsieur ban
moi j'attends un peu de regarder
vraiment ce qu'il ya derrière ce rc ep
parce que d'abord ce que je constate
c'est que la l'offensive chinoise pour
aboutir à un accord a été facilitée par
le retrait de leur renoncement par les
états unis de son propre projet il
m'entend je pense qu'ils et elles
accordent un traité de trans pacific rim
entend
mais il faut s'habituer et donc c'est
d'abord donc il ya eu un premier acte
politique qui le retrait américain
on ne peut rien et il ya eu un deuxième
acte politique si l'initiative chinoise
bon je pense qu'il faut regarder ça de
très près parce que la chine avait déjà
des relations avec plus une bonne partie
des pays signataires de cet accord des
relations de libre échange donc sa force
ça fait un peu une addition de
d'engagements pris antérieurement
donc moi je suis plutôt réservé sur
l'analyse pour pour l'instant de
l'initiative d'autant plus que
parallèlement à cette initiative
économique qui lie à d'autres
initiatives plutôt militaire qui
regroupe pas les mêmes et qui n'exclut
plus la chine
je ne pense en particulier aux accords
que parce l'australie le japon
l'inde qui n'est pas partie de cet
accord est donc ce qui l'affaiblît un
petit peu qui n'est pas parti du rc ep
mais par contre 1 australie japon
sont en train d'agir ensemble pour avoir
une collaboration militaire
donc tout ça fait un petit peu paraît un
peu confus dans l'état actuel des choses
et donc pense qu'il faut attendre un
petit peu de clarification de ce qui
peut se passer
ceci étant la bonne réponse pour nom
mais vous l'avez anticiper c'est d'avoir
une stratégie à double pacifique qui
nous est propre qui nous permettent
d'avoir des relations avec l'ensemble de
ses partenaires majeurs et c'est ce que
nous faisons parce qu'il ya eu une
initiative prise par le président macron
dans son déplacement en australie en mai
2018 pour marquer les finalités
prioritaires de la stratégie à nos
passifs hic à laquelle nous considérons
nous appartenons puisque vous l'avez
rappelé vous même
nous sommes présents physiquement
territorialement dans cet espace alors
les grands enjeux sont la fois la
stabilité et la paix dans la zone la
lutte contre le terrorisme la
préservation de multilatéralise les
enjeux climatiques et aussi la promotion
des biens communs mondiaux donc
travaillons sur ces bases là avec les
uns et les autres en ayant passé des
accords avec l'australie avec l'inde
avec le japon et je voudrais vous le
dire parce que c'était un combat que
nous avons mené depuis depuis longtemps
nous avons obtenu le statut de
partenaire de développement de l'asian
et donc ça sera ça va de renforcer notre
présence dans la zone et notre capacité
à développer une stratégie indo
pacifique qu'ils soient inclusives
donc il n'exclut pas la chine ils soient
inclusives sur les enjeux que nous avons
affiché et c'est je crois la bonne
logique entre à mettre en oeuvre
d'autant plus que l'union européenne je
suis dotée elle aussi d'une même
stratégie
indo pacifique qui ce qui peut être tout
à fait partenariale pour nous on voilà
ce que je peux dire à ce moment
j'attends de regarder très concrètement
ce que signifie vraiment cette ce héros
ce rc ep
alors sur monsieur herbillon g j'ai à
plusieurs reprises fait l'inventaire des
difficultés que nous avons avec la
turquie sans complaisance mais parce que
cela induit des déstabilisations majeur
ce que je n'ai pas souligné peut-être
suffisamment encore mais je le dis ici
c'est en même temps l'apparition d'une
espèce de connivence conflictuelle sur
un certain nombre de théâtre entre la
russie la turquie jeudi connivence
conflictuelle les deux en même temps
mais ce qu'on a vu là sur le
haut-karabagh mais on voit en libye ce
qu'on voit ailleurs c'est un peu cette
situation là avec chacun essayant de
créer sans son domaine d'influencé
mais là où mon propos est assez ferme je
le crois l'avoir dit tout à l'heure
c'est dans le fait que ce sont nos
intérêts et les intérêts européens qui
sont remises en cause
j'en ai fait la déclinaison alors je
vais pas vous dire monsieur rebellion la
liste des actes que nous attendons
non parce que nous sommes en public et
donc je vais pas m'adresser à monsieur
erdogan par votre intermédiaire en
disant voilà ce qu'il faut voilà ce
qu'il faudrait faire
je pense que les les deux dans les
oblige j'ai dit mais je pense que le la
thur la turquie doit savoir ce qu'elle
doit faire
il faut qu'elle fasse un choix je crois
l'avoir dit tout à l'heure je le redis
là où c'est le choix de la confrontation
où c'est le choix de la collaboration
si c'est le choix de la collaboration
nous sommes prêts au dialogue mais il
faut poser des actes pour que nous
démontrer que tout ce qui a été fait
depuis plusieurs mois on revient dessus
ce n'est plus la même logique mais ça
suppose des apd significatif donc ils
peuvent en faire on a quelques idées sur
le sujet mais mais je ne citais une il
peut y en avoir d'autres
c'est à eux de prendre la mesure de la
tente que nous avons nous conte les
européens ce que j'observe néanmoins sur
la relation avec la turquie c'est que
nous les réserves et les interrogations
que nous avons nous depuis plusieurs
mois en fait cette évolution vous le
savez a commencé en 2016 après le coup
d'état raté en turquie c'est depuis
cette date il ya cette inflexion
accéléré à la fois d'une espèce
d'expansionnisme islamo nationaliste et
de politique du fait accompli et de
politique de provocation
bon au fur et à mesure que l'on avance
on sent qu'il y a de la part de nos
collègues européens ou prise de
conscience que ça peut plus rester comme
ça et donc à la réunion du conseil
européen du 17 juin au 11 le conseil
européen sera amené à se saisir de la
réalité de la situation et prendre les
idées et les initiatives qui convient de
prendre à ce moment là je veux pas vous
dire plus mais on attend de la part de
la turquie d'ici là les actes
nécessaires pour savoir si on est dans
une stratégie de confrontation ou de
collaboration
c'est de leur responsabilité dans la
série d initiatives que l'on peut
prendre à l'égard de la turquie à un
panel extrêmement large justement variés
que les turcs peuvent très bien
identifiés et donc voilà on en est là à
l'heure où je vous parle donc pas je
pense pas et donc voit bien mais les
sujets et nous avons d'ailleurs je veux
le dire avec que la présidence allemande
du minimum du moment mais même au delà
même du fait qu'ils assument la
présidence eu une discussion très
approfondie sur la situation est donc ça
m'amène à la présidence allemande de
lieux qui a été très très particulière
puisque modem interrogé sur cette
présidence je pense qu'elle a été
dominée par la crise pandémique c'est
évident mais il y a eu des d'autres
sujets qui ont avancé je pense aux
particuliers à la relation union
européenne chine d' le sommet de
septembre qui a permis de passer des
messages de fermeté et en particulier
sur le plan commercial et sur le plan
économique à l'égard de la chine et nous
attendons d'ici la fin de l'année
plusieurs résultats sur lequel ils se
mobilisent la raison de la fin de la
négociation du bric site des avancées
sur le pacte asile et migration des
progrès sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui d'un paquet qui doit être
normalement validé au conseil du haut du
onze du 10 et 11
et puis un engagement clair sur sur le
climat si c'est des sujets qui sont dans
la dans la discussion actuellement et ça
permettra de cristalliser la qualité
d'une présidence allemande qui a été je
trouve de beaux ni vraiment de bonne
qualité en particulier pour traverser
cette crise pandémique et puis qui a
permis aussi le la mise en oeuvre du du
plan de relance qui a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises or maintenant on va
passer à la présidence portugaise puis
la présence lowen puis l'appui la nôtre
nous on est déjà dans la préparation
mais je me suis rendu
et et en slovénie et en os portugal pour
préparer la suite avec avec nos
partenaires et nous avons avec la maj et
à berlin vente hier une poursuite de
conversation sur tous les sujets que je
viens d'évoquer là pour essayer de finir
l'année à voir un conseil européen de
grande qualité et si possible avec
l'ampleur des sujets qui sont sur la
table parce qu on a déjà évoqué tout à
l'heure beaucoup de sujets mais vous
voyez l'ampleur des packs du paquet qui
devrait être discuté et on l'espère
tranchée au conseil européen du 17 on je
sais pas comment ils devront tout faire
enfin on va essayer sur monsieur bruno
joncour sur le multilatéralisme
je crois je crois que ce qui à ce que ce
qui a changé c'est que le
multilatéralisme renouvelé que nous
voulons initier
il est renouvelé sur deux juge et d'une
part sur la nécessité d'obtenir des
résultats
moi ce que j'appelle le multilatéralisme
par la preuve et d'autre part il doit
être renouvelée en termes d'
associations de tous les acteurs
pertinents
sur le sujet les sujets concernés sur le
multilatéral de demain il ne peut pas se
faire uniquement à partir des états
l'exemple a été donné dès hier par les
les accords de paris sur le sur le
climat la com 21 puisque à la coop 21
on a eu un résultat du multilatéralisme
et on a aimé un résultat avec une
approche multi acteurs les deux il pense
que sur l'ensemble des sujets et des
défis de notre de notre planète il faut
aboutir à cette logique là le forum de
paris sur la paix qui a été initiée par
le président de la république en 2018 a
été dans cette cohérence où on invite
les acteurs apporter des initiatives
concrètes sur les thèmes de mobilisation
du nouveau multilatéralisme
regardez l'édition de la troisième
édition du forum de paris
a rassemblé douze mille personnes en
ligne évidemment mais quand même ça
montre qu'il ya une véritable volonté
d'action commune et cela a permis de
réunir des représentants de la société
civile des ong des états des entreprises
des collectivités locales bref c'est
comme ça qu'on peut faire avancer les
grands sujets qui sont devant nous que
ce soit l'environnement la santé
le numérique la lutte contre les infos
démis l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est la nouvelle donne du
multilatéralisme et dans l'initiative
que nous avions prises avec keiko masse
donc légalement à new york l'année
dernière
c'est dans cette démarche que nous
inscrivions et jeu qu'on se trouve
qu'elle rencontre un vrai succès il faut
se battre sur cette nouvelle donne qui
est une donne inclusive et partagez vous
m'avez parlé de la pêche croit avoir
répondu en partie
je sais que vous êtes très préoccupé par
ce sujet aujourd'hui il faut il faut les
sujets majeurs c'est l'accès de la bande
des six 12000 britannique et le respect
de la stabilité relative qui est la base
de leur robe bleue la stabilité relative
ça veut dire le respect des droits
historiques c'est à dire que il fut un
temps empêché la et donc c'est tel ou
tel armement qui pêchaient là telle ou
telle pays qui pêchait dans cette zone
et donc ils gardent cette priorité
historique que l'on a connu aussi dans
la relation avec l'espagne je sais plus
qui me parlait tout à l'heure de la
difficulté de relation
de pêche je suis gentil je reviens sur
vos déclarations
j'ai connu il se trouve qu'à un moment
donné j'ai été chargée de ce sujet là au
niveau national que j'étais de la mer à
un moment donné il y avait la période
espagnole où on a eu des situations très
conflictuelle mais on a fini par trouver
une voie d'entendre en respectant les
droits historiques et donc je pense que
c'est là dessus qu'il faut qu'il faut
agir en respectant à la fois l'histoire
est là le les les zones qui sont dans
responsabilité la souveraineté des états
je pense que la zone des 6 12 milles
mais en même temps en assurant de que
les l'histoire de l'action économique
des pêcheurs de tel ou tel pays doivent
être respectées pour prendre en compte
la nouvelle donne ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui la position des britanniques
et c'est ce qui empêche de mettre en
oeuvre un des sujets qui empêche de
mettre en oeuvre les accords futurs s'il
peut y en avoir un
d'ici peu ils peuvent se mettre en
oeuvre je voudrais quand même pour
repréciser à monsieur jean cours que
nous préparons des mesures
d'accompagnement sur la pêche en
particulier par le renforcement du fonds
européen pour les affaires maritimes et
la pêche de fameux ferrand qui doit être
renforcée dans le cadre de l'activité
pêche et du retrait éventuellement des
eaux du retrait du royaume britannique
du royaume uni et de la non pas de no
deal qui pourrait intervenir est
également le fonds bric site de 5
milliards d'euros qui a été décidé par
les chefs d'état pour dont une partie
importante pourrait revenir à la pêche
pour éviter des désastres qui pourrait
se produire par une attitude
intransigeante de odieux royaume uni
excusez moi de ma prononciation vigiles
du mal à parler au bout de quelques
heures avec le basque
surtout que j'avais ce matin déjà gelé
depuis vite depuis je parle depuis 2009
alors monsieur g non c'était monsieur
monsieur el guerrab sur le l'azerbaïdjan
nous avons des relations et depuis
longtemps mais que l'azerbaïdjan
nous avons une relation de cordialité il
faut il faut le dire c'est pas ça
n'empêche pas nos peu notre position
globale sur le conflit du haut karabagh
le président chirac a fait faire un
temps un voyage d'état extrêmement
important à bas coûts le président
sarkozy est aussi présent hollande aussi
il ya une histoire de relations entre le
l'azerbaïdjan et la france avec qui a
donné des résultats ou ce que monsieur
el guerrab rappelle oui c'est vrai mais
je suis monsieur rendu moi même à bas
coût pour constater le développement de
l'université franco azerbaïdjan et riz
et qui marche bien donc vous tout ça est
vrai ça n'empêche pas qu'on puisse
parler très clairement avec avec des
azéri pour leur dire que il faut
s'engager dans un processus de
discussions pour aboutir à une solution
durable de cette situation conflictuelle
voilà donc je ne vais pas d'autre chose
à rajouter à l'observation de monsieur
el guerrab nous sommes dans il fallait
que cette ce cessez le feu interviennent
il faut faire en sorte que les zones
dont du cessez-le-feu soit clarifiée je
les ai exposé dans vos propos de départ
et nous devons rester je les dis pour
lui mais je le dis aussi pour d'autres
intervenants sur ce sujet nous avons
notre mission c'est d'être de rester
coprésident du groupe dit groupe de
minsk
parce que d'abord les parties nous le
demandent les arméniens nous le demande
un moment donné on entendait dire il
fallait qu'on ne pas que nous soyons pas
dire la neutralité être président c'est
pas être neutre
cet équilibre est dans l'analyse et si
nous ne sommes pas là nous avec les
états unis d'amérique et et la russie
pour être garant de la peau du processus
on ne répond pas aux demandes des uns et
des autres et en particulier aux
demandes des arméniens qui souhaite que
nous restions parties prenantes
autrement la notion d' équilibre ne ne
marchera pas donc je le dis avec
beaucoup de clarté parce que aujourd'hui
il ya un débat au sénat sur la
reconnaissance du haut karabagh
l'arménie elle même
à ma connaissance n'a pas reconnu de
haut karabagh l'arménie elle même alors
parfois les mains des roches quoi si
l'arménie elle même ne reconnaît pas le
haut karabagh et qu'on demande à la
france de le reconnaître en étant en
même temps coprésidents du groupe de
minsk que ça devient un peu acrobatique
et donc notre logique et l'éclair
clarification de l'accord de cessez le
feu il ya eu trois tentatives
c'est la quatrième seulement pied abouti
et la abouti parce que au dernier moment
il fallait accélérer la russie en a pris
l'initiative
autrement c'est stepanek air qui étaient
prises par les forces azéries il fallait
bloquer et
enrichie raison de bloquer maintenant il
faut traduire tout cela dans une
démarche inclusive à laquelle nous
allons essayer de contribuer le mieux
possible
oui monsieur monsieur hutin d'abord j'ai
beaucoup parlé de l'europe parce qu'en
fait le président m'a cité dans ses
propos introductifs a parlé des sujets
européens en priorité est donc j'ai
essayé d'y répondre mais par ailleurs
moi je suis convaincu que choisir
l'europe ça n'a jamais voulu dire en
tout cas pas pour moi et donc de ce côté
là je vais vous rejoindre ça n'a jamais
voulu dire renoncer la nation au
contraire il me semble pour moi que la
souveraineté notre pays est renforcée
par la souveraineté l'affirmation de la
souveraineté européenne
que ce soit sur le climat que ce soit
sur le commerce sur les grands enjeux à
chaque fois avec l'europe la france pèse
plus sur la défense de ces valeurs et
donc pense que le vrai patriote
ce n'est pas pour moi celui qui qui fait
le choix du repli national mais c'est
celui qui au nom de ces valeurs
nationales fait le choix de l'engagement
européen
donc je suis pas certain d'ailleurs que
nous soyons des accords dans ce que je
vous dis là mais je je percute bien
votre votre observation j'ai répondu sur
la pêche et je crois à peu près sur la
turquie
je vais répondre à madame dumas sur la
turquie aussi je sais que c'était un peu
dans le sur les mêmes sujets pâle pas
sur la même formulation mais sur les
mêmes sujets
sur wes sur monsieur meyer habib vous
dites que le logiciel est périmé je ne
le crois pas je vais pas revenir sur
toutes vos propos je connais vos
orientations votre détermination votre
engagement vous connaissez aussi les
positions que je défends nom du
gouvernement mais aussi qu'ils sont
partagés au niveau européen
je vous rappelle que nous avons souligné
l'avancée que représentait le fait que
les émirats arabes unis le royaume de
bahreïn et le soudan s'engagent dans la
normalisation de leurs relations avec
israël
nous avons fait ça très clairement c'est
un communiqué venu de ma part pour dire
que nous sommes favorables à cette
reconnaissance parce que toutes les
initiatives qui permet de réduire les
tensions régionales sont de bonnes
initiatives et nous avons toujours
considéré que l'esprit nouveau dont
témoignent ces annonces doit être
maintenant utilisés pour travailler à la
reprise du dialogue entre les israéliens
et les palestiniens sur la base de deux
paramètres agréés par les nations unies
c'est à dire l'établissement de deux
états dans le cadre du droit
international
c'est sûr nous de ce point qui nous
différencie c'est pour ça que vous
estimez que le logiciel est périmé moi
je ne le pense pas et donc il faut
maintenant agir pour que l'on puisse à
partir de ces avancées de normalisation
s'est avancée de reconnaissance on
puisse ouvrir un dialogue positif sur
l'iran non c'est je pense que vous
faites une erreur d'optique c'est pas
l'iran qui s'est retiré du cepeo à ça à
ma connaissance sur les états unis
voilà donc vous avez des renseignements
ne s'est pas retirée l'iran ensuite
après le départ des etats-unis a
commencé à détricoter les éléments de
l'accord du gcp aux as nous avons mis le
doigt sur ses insuffisances et nous
avons indiqué que nous condamnions c'est
rupture d'engagement de l'iran qui
justifiait ces des ruptures d'engagement
partiel et successifs de la cause des
pays bas par le retrait des états unis
en raison du non retour des effets
économiques que les rangs pouvez
bénéficier de l'accord de vienne
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui donc je
note avec intérêt que dans une
déclaration du 16 novembre au moins neuf
ans le président-élu byden annoncé qu'il
voulait reprendre les discussions pour
entrer dans le revenir dans les six
pirates sous des formes à déterminer
nous allons rentrer dans cette nouvelle
logique et nous sommes partenaires de
cela mais il faudra attendre
effectivement que l'administration de
nouvelles sur en place ne nous avons
toujours dit aux iraniens que il prônait
il avait une mauvaise réaction face à
une mauvaise décision avons toujours dit
que la décision de retrait des
américains de l'accord était une
mauvaise décision monsieur habib la
bible c'est je lui ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises et que la réaction
iranienne est une mauvaise réaction face
à une mauvaise décision
maintenant il faut essayer de trouver un
une reprise de confiance et nous allons
essayer d'y contribuer voilà sur
monsieur meyer dit après
madame madame dumas j'ai des désaccords
avec vous que je peux identifier
je ne suis absolument pas la posture
concernant la côte d'ivoire avec la
posture concernant la guinée conakry
il faut être très clair en guinée
conakry il y a eu une réforme de la
constitution pour permettre au président
alpha condé de se représenter au delà
des demandes a en nous n'avons pas et le
président les élections ont eu lieu il
ya eu quelques des complications il ya
il ya des difficultés dans je cherche la
date des élections que je ne trouve pas
il y a eu des difficultés à la suite de
deux de ces élections
le référendum qui avait abouti à la au
changement de constitution lui-même fait
été marquée par des violences
et donc nous considérons que il revient
au président alpha condé de poser des
gestes d'ouverture pour apaiser la
tension qui existe toujours en ce moment
dans son pays
en ce qui concerne la côte d'ivoire le
président ouattara avait annoncé
publiquement et très concrètement sa
volonté de se retirer au terme de deux
mandats
il se trouve que le candidat qui
était susceptible d'être candidat pour
l'élection pour l'élection il se trouve
que le candidat qui devait représenter
le parti de monsieur ouattara monsieur
coulibaly est décédé il était en
campagne on ne peut pas suspecter
monsieur ouattara d'avoir organiser tout
ça pour lui-même il était en colère dure
campagne ça s'est passé un mois avant ou
un mois et demi avant l'élection
je suis allé à l'enterrement de monsieur
coulibaly qui était premier ministre
alors il se trouve que ils se reprennent
le président ouattara s'est représenté
devant cette situation particulière
c'est son choix
ce que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui c'est
mais c'est pas du tout le même
dispositif constitutionnel que donc donc
guinée conakry c'est la raison pour
laquelle le président d'un cran à
féliciter monsieur ouattara de son
élection et n'a pas félicité monsieur
alpha condé pour l'instant donc soyons
clair sur ce sujet je rajoute que nous
souhaitons que rome en côte d'ivoire les
les actes d'ouverture de sérénité puisse
se faire il ya eu des ouvertures qui ont
été effectuées à l'égard du président
bédié il ya eu des annonces d'ouverture
à l'égard de monsieur gbagbo
c'est donc le président
ouattara poursuivre dans cette logique
là et j'espère qu'elle pourra aboutir à
une situation plus plus sereine dans ce
pays mais je différencie bien les deux
situations
quant à l'élection niger parce que vous
complétez avec le niger madone dumas
constatons ensemble que le processus
électoral au niger se déroule pour
l'instant dans des conditions reconnu
par la communauté internationale y
compris sur les cartes d'électeurs y
compris sur l'a10 la mise en oeuvre des
bureaux de vote
voilà donc j'ai que le président
issoufou a dit j'ai fait deux mandats
j'arrête
pourquoi voulez-vous l'accusé en plus
j'avoue que parfois je n'ai sur ce je
vous comprends pas et dont je voudrais
vous dire aussi que sur les accords
migratoires avec la turquie nous
remplissons nos obligations l'europe
rempli ses obligations y compris dans
dispositif qu'on appelle l'afrique
la vérité nous sommes au rendez vous
financier
je comprends que la turquie veulent
toujours un peu plus mais je sais que la
turquie a une tâche lourde de recevoir
des réfugiés vous l'avez tiges partage
ce sentiment mais faut pas dire que nous
remplissons pas nos obligations ni nous
ni les européens à cet égard
monsieur lecoq je connais votre
attachement la situation au sahara
occidental
ce que je sais que je ne partage pas
c'est que dans vos propos vous
considérez que finalement tout ça c'est
la faute de la france
faut quand même pas exagérer nous sommes
membres du conseil de sécurité ne sommes
pas les seuls et je crois que ce serait
vraiment de l'ingérence et je sais que
vous êtes opposés à l'ingérence que nous
soyons nous mêmes les acteurs d'une
relation compliquée entre le peuple
sahraoui le maroc et l'algérie
ce sur quoi je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est qu' il est temps que il y ait un
processus de paix qui se met en oeuvre
et que le fait que le président en
colère qui était l'ancien président de
l'allemand qui a dû renoncer à sa
mission pour des raisons de santé
mais tant qu'il soit remplacé pour qu'on
rentre dans un processus de paix et
parce que si on n'entend pas de
processus de paix alors ça devient
conflictuel et sur ce point je suis
d'accord avec vous sur les autres points
pour me pour monsieur anglade
je ne vois pas d'autre solution que de
trouver un accord avec
les hongrois et les polonais qu'ils sont
ils se rendre compte qu'ils sont en
train de bloquer complètement l'union
européenne parce que la voie d'une
coopération renforcée que vous avez
évoquées en pointillés au sens des
traités européens qui fait qu'on
pourrait faire une c'est une coopération
renforcée uniquement sur ce sujet là
nécessiterait beaucoup de travailleurs
ça ne concerne pas le budget européen
dont il faudrait un accord
intergouvernemental en dehors des
traités pour aboutir une solution qui ne
soit pas celle là et ça à mon avis ça
prend du temps
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et donc je
pense pas que c'est la bonne solution
donc il faut essayer de par la
persuasion s'y emploie la présence
allemande s'y emploient d'aboutir il est
président et les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement s'y employer pour obtenir
un accord et pour montrer à la hongrie
et à la pologne que bat d'abord ya un
droit européen c'est comme ça que les
engagements de vannes sur les valeurs
que nous avons partagé ensemble et qu'il
faut aboutir
un résultat qui est dans leur propre
intérêt sur la question de monsieur
mbaye
bon j'ai pas beaucoup de choses à
rajouter par rapport à ce que vous avez
dit la france est ton soutien complet à
l'égard des africains des africains
doivent gérer souverainement cette
monnaie qui commence et nous sommes tout
à fait favorables à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir des participations des
accompagnements parlementaire mais c'est
au pas nous africains de le décider
nous pensons que tout cela est vraiment
au service de l'intégration monétaire
régional c'est une avancée alors il a
été un peu freiné je pense que vous
allez le dire pendant votre rapport aux
raison de la pandémie dont il ya des
dispositions un agenda qui est dû et de
remy mais il importe que nous puissions
accompagner les européens dans cette
dynamique les africains dans cette
dynamique mais
si beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
toutes ces réponses alors nous allons
maintenant passer à une autre table de
questions je vais vraiment ou demander à
mes collègues vraiment d'être concis
dans les questions pour que tout le
monde puisse poser ces questions je vais
donner la parole à jean louis bourlanges
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre bonjour je voudrais
revenir j'ai beaucoup de questions mais
je posais pas tout parce que notre
président serait effrayer mais je
voudrais revenir sur la sphère
arménienne je trouve que dans jeu je
trouve que dans cette affaire
moi j'ai très bien compris la position
de la france et j'ai trouvé que vous
fassiez le maximum j'ai d'ailleurs à nos
amis arménien âgé je sais plus tôt
indiqué que la solution si salif vous
aider et qu'il fallait ne pas
surenchérir
cela dit force est de constater
aujourd'hui que les russes et les
ailiers et lecture nous ont en quelque
sorte rouler dans la farine
je vous en fais pas leurs proches mais
c'est ainsi l'article de l'isérois ya
quelques jours dans le monde et est très
claire et quand il dit que la russie a
consciemment et délibérément laissé
l'arménie se faire écraser c'est exact
et de nous voyons bien que il y avait
une connivence entre le président en
relief la russie et indirectement le
premier ministre le plus souvent en
tueur donc nous sommes dans une
situation
il me paraît aux avants la question de
ce que nous faisons maintenant le groupe
de minsk on est vice-président très bien
mais en réalité nous n'avons pas cartes
en main dans cette affaire et je crois
qu'il faut autant en le mesurer et
l'assumé alors vous dites et nous voyons
bien que sur plein de choses sur la
libye où nous avons quand même cédé à
des menaces de guerre les les menaces
tout était pour le fait qu'au classement
gardes françaises étaient les menaces de
guerre nous sommes dans une situation où
les turcs viole la légalité en grèce
donc je trouve monsieur le ministre que
vous êtes c'est normal vous êtes
diplomate
mais je trouve que vous êtes quand même
un peu les initiants quand vous dites
que la question aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si la turquie doit préférer la
confrontation à la coopération ou la
coopération à la confrontation
je crois que le choix est clair pour la
turquie elle a choisi la confrontation
en revanche le choix des packs terre
pour nous de savoir si nous manifestons
de la solidarité européenne avec nos
amis je sais que la france joue dans ce
sens donc je ne vous en fais pas leurs
proches mais si l'art si nous jouons la
solidarité ou si nous jouons ce cas la
tendance du beaucoup la résignation
je crois que c'est là le problème
solidarité ou résignation de notre part
bien davantage que confrontation aux
coopérations
du côté de la turquie car je craque et
las de ce côté là le choix était fait
merci beaucoup aux chers collègues and
john t bonjour est ce que vous
m'entendez est-ce que vous m'entendez oh
oui très bien et serait bien m'entendez
oui monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
pour vous exposer je voudrais tout
d'abord en préambule gérer vite monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre est
donc vous en tant que français élu par
vous le savez des français qui se
trouvent à l'étranger vous témoigner de
la fierté qu'ont beaucoup de nos
ressortissants si ce n'est pas tous à
l'égard de la politique étrangère de la
france de notre positionnement dans des
circonstances extrêmement complexe que
vous avez longuement exposé et je
voudrais saluer les initiatives et les
démarches que vous entreprenez pour
défendre notre position
notre existence dans le monde notre
influence dans le monde dont on sait
qu'elle n'est pas évidente à défendre et
que si nous n'avions pas des gens
quelques vous tels que notre président
aujourd'hui je ne donnerai pas cher de
notre présence et de notre influence
dans 20 à 30 ans donc soyez ans
remercier je voulais vous parler d'un
point très précis vous avez abordé tout
à l'heure qui est le fait que vous avez
dit non au sens européen du terme sommes
très attaquées actuellement et nous
savons que notamment s'agissant de la
france on a un sentiment anti-français
qui s'est développée dans un certain
nombre de pays je vais aller très
rapidement à ma question
ça changera également souligné le fait
que vous avez parlé de l'affluence du
rck le rôle sans mon joué par la turquie
je voudrais également souligner le fait
que la turquie joue un rôle également
relativement sombre dans un autre coin
du monde que sont l'indonésie la
malaisie et le bangladesh alors ma
question c'est il s'agit de comment
défendre notre modèle laïc et
universaliste aujourd'hui et donc je
note que nos voisins enfin certains pays
je pense aux états unis d'une part et au
royaume uni d'autres pas honte une
diplomatie culturelle que nous n'avons
pas donc si je comprends selon l'article
de la loi 1905 la république française
ne reconnaît ne salarie ni ne
subventionne aucun culte
néanmoins notre société les reconnaît
preuve en est par exemple que nous avons
un ambassadeur au vatican
donc monsieur le ministre j'aimerais
savoir comment nous pourrions est-ce que
sept modèles ce modèle pardon de
diplomatie culturelle avec le
sous-secrétaire d'état aux états unis où
le haut-commissaire au culte au forint
schiste est ce que ce modèle de
diplomatie culturelle n'est pas un
modèle dont nous pourrions nous inspirer
pour défendre et propager et expliquer
notre modèle laïc et universaliste je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue bruno fuchs
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
jusqu'à vous l'avez noté ce matin cette
commission a adopté le projet de loi qui
vise à terme enclenché le processus pour
supprimer le français fall faire
remplacer par par l'écho le président de
la république dans une interview au
journal jeune afrique a posé les bases
de cette nouvelle relation entre la
france et le continent africain nouvelle
relation illustre également par la
restitution
de biens culturels au bénin et au
sénégal
c'est un processus qui a été lancé mais
c'est une interview de la république que
résout autant de questions qu'elle n'en
ouvre d'autres
alors mes interrogations va être très
très précis tourneront autour de la
liberté d'expression des libertés
publiques vous avez parlé de la côte
d'ivoire nous n'avons en côte d'ivoire
cinq parlementaires qui sont toujours
privés de liberté plus anciens salins
lobognon qui est bientôt détenu depuis
un an il a vu son avocat en février
dernier pour la dernière fois et entendu
par un juge en août sans avocat nous
avons également affi n'guessan ancien
premier ministre député qui est en
prison sans qu'on puisse se connaître le
lieu de sa détention certainement
aujourd'hui une détention dans un camp
militaire et donc cinq parlementaires
aux dalles d'autres membres politiques
également qu'ils sont privés de liberté
le président ouattara devrait procéder à
son investiture le 14 décembre prochain
monsieur le ministre à ce que vous
pourriez nous affirmer ici que
l'ensemble des forces politiques et
diplomatiques de la france fera tout il
mettra tout son poids pour que c'est
députés soient libérés et qu'on obtienne
ce geste là notamment avant le 14
et puis une question sur le tchad ou une
nouvelle constitution est à à l'étude
qui vise à ce que on ne puisse pas
prétendre être présent de la république
avant 45 ans on n'est pas là dans le
renouvellement des générations
politiques
quelle est la position de la france par
rapport à cette disposition de la
constitution chadian merci beaucoup
chers collègues alors sylvain waserman
après se prépare pierre-henri du mans et
nicole le p oui bonjour merci monsieur
le président bonjour monsieur le
ministre je serai je serai rapide
j'ai deux questions en réalité la
première elle sera rapide mais elle
concerne la situation de quelqu'un que
vous connaissez bien monsieur ministre
maurice kamto vous aviez principal
opposant politique au cameroun il est
aujourd'hui en résidence surveillée
il ya beaucoup de d'expression y compris
niveau international sur ses soutiens et
d'inquiétudes sur son cas vous aviez
déjà vous étiez déjà intervenu fortement
je veux savoir quelle est votre analyse
de la situation sur cet aspect aucun
monde et deuxième question elle n'a rien
à voir elle concerne le mercosur
le parlement européen vient de dire
quand l'état à l'occasion d'un vote sur
le rapport de la commission en matière
de commerce extérieur qu'en l'état le
contrat du mercosur aide n'est pas
acceptable
les espagnols les italiens les portugais
restent très en faveur évidemment pour
une raison notamment historique de cet
accord du mercosur
donc ma question est la suivante sachant
que à la fois le groupe renew à la fois
que nos collègues
lr français du groupe ppe ont voté
massivement contre une adoption du
mercosur en l'état comment voyez vous la
suite des opérations puisque en l'état
actuel des choses et une réunion
importante à la commission demain sur le
sujet mais en l'état actuel des choses
il ya toujours cet accord qui est sur la
table et qui nous semble en tout cas
beaucoup de parlementaires inacceptable
en l'état
j'aurais voulu votre position merci
beaucoup aux chimistes
merci beaucoup cher collègue pierre
henri dumont merci monsieur le président
plusieurs questions pour monsieur le
ministre je remercie sa présence parmi
nous cet après midi la première sur sur
le break site vous avez expliqué ne pas
vouloir être l'otage du calendrier donc
préféré ne pas avoir d'accord que la
voir un mauvais accord sans quoi je
partage parfaitement vos propos
cependant pensez vous qu'il y a toujours
une possibilité de négocier ou d'ouvrir
une nouvelle phase de négociations post
31 décembre
et donc est ce que la deadline du 31
décembre est vraiment la dernière limite
est d'après vous d'ailleurs puisqu'on
sait très bien que 31 décembre ne peut
être qu'une limite ultime à quel moment
estimez vous qu'il le sera acquis que
nous arriverons dans un audi laquelle à
quel moment du calendrier d'ici les
prochains jours toujours sur la question
du break sites sur le territoire je
représente du calaisis nous avons un un
sujet sur une directive européenne à
2818 c'est eux qui correspond à la
question du duty free puisque cette
directive son article 14 interdit le
duty free
tout du moins n'explique pas de façon
très claire sur les questions de
transport de marchandises par voies
ferroviaire ce qui au 1er janvier s'il
n'y a pas d'accord puisque le royaume
uni vient d'un pays tiers ne permettrait
pas d'avoir du duty free dans le
terminal du tunnel sous la manche alors
que on pourrait en avoir au port ce qui
a introduit une distorsion de
concurrence assez massive pensez vous
pouvoir puisque la position de bercy et
de dire qu'il n'est pas possible de
transiger par rapport à ces directives
rouvrir les négociations sur cette
directive pour inclure le ferroviaire
dans dans cette possibilité une autre
question pour changer de champ sur la
turquie pour compléter la question de
mon collègue michel herbillon puisqu'en
réalité aujourd'hui la question est
celle des critères d'adhésion est ce que
la turquie doit continuer ce process
d'adhésion à l'union européenne
si on devait reprendre de zéro
aujourd'hui la critère ne la turquie ne
satisfait plus les critères de
copenhague sur les trois critères pur
clairement identifiée tout cas sur les
deux premiers c'est à dire la mise en
place d'institutions stables
garantissant l'état de droit la
démocratie les droits de l'homme le
respect des minorités leur protection
la turquie ne satisfait pas ce critère
en particulier quand on parle de respect
de la souveraineté des autres états
membres de l'union européenne et sur le
deuxième point qui est une économie de
marché viable et stable ce n'est pas le
cas non plus puisque la turquie fait
face à sa pire récession 12% en
inflation moins 30% sur le cours de sa
monnaie et donc quelle est votre opinion
là-dessus ce qu'on doit cesser comme les
députés les républicains demandent les
process d'adhésion de la turquie à
l'union européenne et enfin un tout
dernier point toujours en question
d'harmonisation pour prendre au tout
début de votre intervention sur la
question du ski qui était annoncée hier
soir par le président de la république
un ensemble il n'y aurait pas
d'ouverture à noël
comment avoir une harmonisation quand on
sait que la suisse par exemple a déjà
autorisé l'ouverture des stations de ski
dans son pays que certains domaines
skiables français sont partagés avec la
suisse et que l'autriche a annoncé en
septembre dernier peut-être qu'ils vont
voir leurs positions en tout cas mais
ouvrir les stations de ski sans après ce
qui pour reprendre les propos du
chancelier course
je vous remercie merci beaucoup à leur
collègue nicole loupé oui bonjour oui
bonjour oui bonjour c'est entendu oui
très bien
sa collègue ok monsieur le président je
reconnais cette même fini voilà comme
vous le savez dans la commission des
affaires européennes je travaille sur
rapport en ce moment sur la neutralité
carbone avec un collègue député nous
nous rendrons donc les conclusions
courant décembre donc ashton à ce stade
nous pouvons constater l'ampleur des
efforts financiers présentés par l'union
européenne pour atteindre ses objectifs
au moins 30% des 750 milliards d'euros
du plan de relance seront consacrés à
des dépenses liées au climat
c'est un effort incontestable et inédits
dont nous espérons qu'il sera soutenu
par tous les états cela étant si des
efforts financiers consentis par nos
entreprises pour mieux produire sont
massivement soutenues
in fine et nos entreprises restent
soumises à une concurrence sur les prix
et il ya là il me semble une part
d'incompréhension chez nos compatriotes
la cité gare un discours plus offensif
sur notre politique commerciale ne vous
a paraît-il pas nécessaire pour gagner
la bataille politique et environnemental
que largement pouvez-vous revenir sur la
recherche du consensus de paris évoqué
récemment par le président je vous
remercie
kutscher collègues mary clapot merci
monsieur le président est merci charles
michel ministre
la france et l'egypte entretiennent
depuis des années un partenariat
stratégique sur les aspects économiques
politiques sécuritaires et culturels
c'est dans ce cadre que le président
macron a réaffirmé lors de sa visite
officielle au caire en janvier 2019 la
nécessité de veiller au respect des
droits et libertés civiques
car l'egypte continue de se distinguer
sur la scène internationale par ses
violations répétées des droits humains
et de ses engagements internationaux
en effet la répression qui s'exerce à
l'égard la société civile égyptienne
défenseurs des droits humains militants
politiques avocats journalistes ne
faiblit pas cela fait par exemple
aujourd'hui plus d'un dans que la france
dans un dialogue franc et ouvert avec
les autorités égyptiennes
demande la libération ou du moins
l'amélioration de ses conditions de
détention des prisonniers d'opinion
égyptien à l'instar du défenseur des
droits humains rami chatte
or la semaine dernière les autorités
égyptiennes ont arrêté des membres de l'
ong égyptiennes initiative égyptienne
pour les droits personnels le ip r et ce
peu de temps après votre déplacement au
caire et après que ses défenseurs et
rencontrer des représentants
diplomatiques européens dont
l'ambassadeur de france alors monsieur
le ministre comment expliquez vous une
telle attitude des autorités égyptiennes
et à la proche de la visite du président
à 6,6 à paris pourriez vous nous
indiquer quelle position la france
entend tell adoptée à ce sujet merci
merci beaucoup chers collègues
marion laine merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
permettez moi d'insister comme mon
collègue pierre henry du mans sur
l'harmonisation pour les stations de ski
et notamment je pense au domaine bi
national des portes du soleil entre la
suisse et la haute savoie
je suis revenir sur la question je
voulais vous poser
le projet de loi de programmation
relatif au développement solidaire et à
la lutte contre les inégalités mondiales
toujours en cours d'élaboration fixe
parmi les cinq priorités sectorielles la
sécurité alimentaire la nutrition et de
l'agriculture durable dans sa stratégie
internationale
secteur public en 2019 la france a
rappelé son attachement à l'action du
fonds international pour le
développement de l'agriculture le fida
notamment à travers son soutien aux
organisations paysannes et au
développement des filières agricoles
pourtant la sécurité alimentaire et
nutritionnelle l'agriculture et le
développement rural représente seulement
6 % de la totalité de l'aide publique au
développement française
l'agriculture est un levier fondamental
du développement si la france a tenté de
rattraper son retard depuis la création
du fida elle est aujourd'hui en dixième
position des bailleurs quelle va être sa
position pour la 12e reconstitution de
ce fou internationale va-t-elle
décrocher une meilleure place aux au
regard des enjeux car soyons clairs la
population du continent africain va
doubler dans les 30 années à venir
alors comment doubler la production
agricole et la quadrupler d'ici 2050
d'après les chiffres du ministère l'aide
publique au développement allouée à
l'agriculture à la sécurité alimentaire
via le canal multilatérale est
principalement portée par les
contributions au programme de l'union
européenne à hauteur de 177 millions
d'euros au fonds vert pour le climat
pour 36 millions d'euros et au fida pour
160 n 160 parents millions d'euros pour
ce dernier le chiffre interroge en effet
la contribution de la france lors de la
dernière reconstitution du fida s'élever
à seulement 44 millions d'euros
quand celle de l'italie est à 55
millions celles de l'allemagne à plus de
60 millions d'euros et celle de la chine
à plus de 540 millions pouvez vous donc
nous éclairer sur les chiffres du
ministère et ses 160 millions d'euros a
priori consacré au fida au titre de la
paix des multilatéral jour merci merci
beaucoup cher collègue jean michel
clément
oui tout mon temps dit oui très bien
chers collègues je m'entendais très bien
merci beaucoup
oui monsieur le ministre je vous
souhaite revenir sur les actes
terroristes commis par le régime iranien
en europe et les suites politiques qui
pourraient y être donné quelques ratés
un retour en arrière puisque bientôt le
27 novembre prochain aura lieu en
belgique un procès concernant des
citoyens iraniens qui ont commis sur le
territoire français en tout cas qui se
préparait à commettre sur notre
territoire un acte terroriste
quatre personnes dont un diplomate
iranien sont actuellement incarcérés en
belgique et leur procès est prévu donc
le 27 novembre de cette semaine la
justice belge a enquêté de manière
indépendante sur les charges retenues
contre ces personnes
par ailleurs lorsqu'on constate
lorsqu'on consulte le dernier rapport
annuel du service fédéral allemand de
sécurité qui a été publié en juillet
2020 on constate effectivement que un
diplomate a été arrêté et il est accusé
en tant qu'employé à plein temps du
ministère des renseignements d'être le
commanditaire d'un attentat à la bombe
planifiée contre lui la réunion annuelle
de l'opposition iranienne près de paris
le 30 juin 2010 8 à villepinte à cette
rencontre participaient des iraniens
bien sûr des citoyens français aussi
mais aussi beau plusieurs personnels et
politiques dont certains de nos
collègues parlementaires élus français
si cette opération terroriste avait
réussi elle aurait sans aucun doute fait
des centaines de morts et beaucoup plus
de blessés et aurait eu un
retentissement international et
diplomatique sans précédent
par ailleurs vous savez le régime
iranien a tenté par et chantages de
retenir en otage une chercheuse franco
iranienne afin de mettre de faire
pression sur la france au sujet de cette
procédure
ce que vous avez vous même qualifié d'
être une action malveillante nature
politique
donc monsieur le ministre hormis le
processus judiciaire
n'est-il pas temps de reconsidérer en
france comme en europe le traitement du
terrorisme d'état iranien parce que
celui-ci avant qu'il ait commis la date
irréparable devrait peut-être être selon
moi est selon nous mais je dirais à
défaut je vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue didier
contant oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez déjà
abordé de très nombreux sujets apporter
des réponses très précises
ce dont nous vous remercions majoré donc
trois questions rapides
premièrement alors le président de la
république défend l'idée d'une autonomie
stratégique européenne la ministre
allemande de la défense dit à kaka a
appelé au réalisme dans un entretien
publié de novembre dernier sur le site
politico en réaffirmant je la cite que
l'otan doit demeurer le pilier de
défense de l'ordre
alors je voudrais savoir comment vous
interpréter cette déclaration et puis
deux autres questions un peu plus
ponctuelle à propos de la stratégie ados
pacifique dont vous avez déjà
abondamment parlé pouvez vous monsieur
le ministre nous préciser la position de
la france afin que taiwan puisse
participer de plein droit à différentes
organisations internationales comme l'om
s est enfin pouvez vous nous indiquer
l'évolution des relations bilatérales
avec djibouti pays avec lequel nous
sommes liés par un accord de défense et
la présence d'une base interarmées mais
nous ne sommes plus les seuls et même en
net recul par rapport aux américains et
surtout aux chinois voilà les trois
questions que je voulais vous poser une
seule liste merci beaucoup chers
collègues juliana tanguy merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
souhaitais vous interroger sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme qui a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises il se trouve que je
suis rapporteur d'observation au titre
de la commission des affaires
européennes pour le projet de loi
parquet européen et je voulais savoir si
donc ce parquet et est compétent pour
les atteintes aux intérêts financiers
uniquement mais le traité permet de
de l'étendre la lutte contre contrôle
terrorisme donc je voulais savoir si la
france avait l'intention de porter
l'élargissement du mandat du parquet
européen la lutte antiterroriste à
l'occasion de sa présidence française au
conseil de l'union europénne ans en 2022
et je me permets aussi une petite
question subsidiaire sur la pêche vous
avez effectivement répondu à pas mal de
nos interrogations mais je voulais quand
même attirer votre attention et j'en
ferai part également la mise de la mer
c'est que certes s'il n'y a pas d'accord
parce qu'il vaut mieux effectivement bon
accord qu'un mauvais accord
si on les britanniques pourraient quand
même respecter les règles du jeu comme
en football quand vous l'avez dit mais
compte tenu de la compétitivité des prix
de la production britannique même si ils
appliquent les règles et les respecte et
qu'on applique des droits de pêche
important enfin je veux dire des droits
de douane et bien là concurrents
risquent la concurrence plus tard et
britanniques risquent d'être quand même
menaçante pour l'activité de ddd
pêcherie française et notamment bretonne
et donc je voulais savoir si au delà du
fait amp qui a été renforcée et du fonds
bric sites qui pourraient aussi venir en
aide aux pêcheurs aux européens et donc
français je voulais savoir si il y avait
également des mesures nationales qui
était envisagé pour pour et parce que
ces fonds là ils sont effectivement
important mais il ya un délai pour les
mobiliser et je crains que certaines
pêcheries finalement ne résiste pas à la
crise
merci merci beaucoup chers collègues du
berger à la ferrière merci monsieur le
président je sens j'essaie d'attirer ma
vidéo mais on me dit que c'est
l'animateur qui donne désactivé voilà
vous entendez oui il ya un cache
peut-être sur ta vidéo oui pardon c'est
moi qui m'y engage ok merci je ne savais
pas que je ne savais pas que deux
caméra était de skopies alors soumis
d'abord merci de votre présence fidèle
mensuel à nos commissions parce que
c'est qu'il ya certains nos collègues
d'autres commissions qui sont jaloux moi
quand je leur ai dit que le ministre
venait vous êtes tous des mois donc
merci encore de ce rendez vous réguliers
vous avez abordé en début de réunion
rapidement le g20 s'est tenu la semaine
dernière organisée par ryad
je crois que le seul fait que aucun de
nos collègues ne soit revenu sur ce g20
montre à quel point en fait ces
résultats sont décevants par rapport à
la hauteur des enjeux
même le secrétaire général des nations
unies autour du cou terrestres a dit
qu'il était déçu par les résultats du
géant
vous avez certes rappelé que le g20 a
consacré l'expression de bien public
mondial pour pour le vaccin contre la
coved 19 mai sur la dette des pays
pauvres
il y avait des attentes sur le climat il
y avait des attentes et et ces attentes
sont vraiment vraiment déçu et même sur
la sur la copie de contact à
l'accessibilité de tous au vaccin
on sait que le manque d'argent demeure
alors que on connaît les conséquences de
cette pandémie sur la paupérisation de
nombreuses régions du monde
moi ce qui pose pour moi la question
quand le sait qu'on a besoin évidemment
de plus de réunions internationales dans
son contexte actuel mais quand le
résultat est si faible jeu repose par un
courrier à votre attention fallait-il
participer à ce g20 organisé par un état
qui certes est un partenaire important
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme mais
qui mais pour lequel nous ne pouvons pas
passer sous silence les atteintes
multiples et répétées aux droits humains
dont ce pays se rend coupable vous
connaissez comme moi le calvaire de ces
centaines de deux femmes militantes
féministes emprisonnés arbitrairement et
dont le seul crime est de demander plus
d'égalité
bien sûr
vous avez toutes et tous entendu que le
jeanne à la toule a entamé une grève de
la faim pour interpeller le monde
justement en amont du g20 sur l'impunité
d'un régime décrié par des dizaines de
angie et puis on connaît bien sur
l'implication de l'arabie saoudite dans
la guerre guerroyaient manière que vous
avez qualifié vous-même de gerbes d'eau
sale guerre avec sale guerre dans
laquelle la commission que l'a rappelé
samedi que mène avec les emmys ravily
porte une responsabilité dans la
terrible crise humanitaire que le loyer
mène même si bien sûr ils ne sont pas
les seules banques leur se confie et je
conclus que la semaine dernière nous
avons consacré notre note 20 commissions
à l'excellent rapport de nos collègues
maires est à barreaux mais un rapport
dans lequel nos exportations d'armes à
destination de ryad avis sont évidemment
interrogé pour leur responsabilité
indirecte dans cette crise terrible que
connaît le yémen
donc ma question monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les avancées de ce g20
organisé par ryad
au delà ce pays aujourd'hui qui pose
quand même vraiment des problèmes à la
fois en termes de droits humains et de
responsabilité dans la tribu militaire
au yémen
si ce n'est effectivement la conseillère
collègues une expression de bien public
mondial pour la koica pour le pacs a
pour mercy mercy et rocco sébastien
nadeau oui merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le drian qui insère sincèrement
à vous remercier de venir à l'assemblée
nationale avec une telle assiduité
le haut représentant et vice-président
de l'union européenne joseph aurel à la
suite de l'élection présidentielle 18
octobre 2020 en guinée s'était interrogé
quant à la crédibilité du résultat
notamment ce qui concerne la remontée
des procès verbaux et le décompte final
des votes
c'est peu dire un mois après les
élections présidentielles guinéennes le
président de la république emmanuel
macron s'est exprimé à son tour dans le
journal jeune afrique sur la situation
en guinée dans les termes suivants le
président condé a une carrière
d'opposant qui aurait justifié qu'il
organise de lui même une bonne
alternance est d'évidence il a organisé
un référendum et un changement de la
constitution
uniquement pour pouvoir garder le
pouvoir c'est pour ça que je ne lui ai
pas encore adressé deux lettres de
félicitations je pense que la situation
est grave en guide et pour sa jeunesse
pour sa qualité démocratique et pour son
avancée
ma question est simple à la suite de
cette prise de parole très forte du
président de la république
que comptez vous proposer pour aider la
démocratie et l'état de droit en guinée
a commencé par faire cesser la
répression orchestrée actuellement par
le gouvernement d'alpha condé à
l'encontre de l'opposition politique et
médiatique
je vous remercie merci beaucoup cher
collègue jacques maire oui merci très
rapidement monsieur le ministre avec
juste une question urgente sur le
karabakh
il avait évoqué la situation tout à
l'heure il ya effectivement aujourd'hui
la table risquent d'épuration ethnique
qui a été interrompue on sait très bien
que les turcs ont cherché aussi à rendre
aux certains endroits absolument
inévitable donc deux éléments sur
laquelle je souhaiterais votre réaction
d'abord peut-on envoyer des soldats sur
le territoire azéri pour garantir la
sécurité des populations arméniennes
est-ce que vous l'envisagez deuxièmement
même si on ne peut pas reconnaître à ce
stade et vous l'avait bien dit un haut
karabakh comme entité comme pays
indépendant
qu'est ce qu'il est possible de faire
pour leur camp
être comme entité au sein de
l'azerbaïdjan on est bien rentrés
effectivement un statut permettant la
sauvegarde de ces populations avant
d'aller vers un autre mais une autre
phase je remercie jacques là qu'est ce
que vous pouvez répéter votre première
question vous le répéter votre question
avant le ministre première question
peut-on aurait des soldats pour assurer
la sécurité des populations
magnette sur le territoire l'azéri
reconnaissance non pas comme entité
indépendante internationale en kit et
permettant de garantir juridiquement la
stabilité de ces populations et leur
avenir éventuelle dans un autre contexte
ita tic merci beaucoup chers collègues
et pour finir notre bérengère poletti
oui donc bon soit il a tout j'espère que
tout le monde l'entend bien monsieur le
ministre depuis plusieurs mois la
violence au cameroun ne cesse de croître
la guerre civile des régions anglophones
des étapes terroriste au nord du pays la
répression politique des autorités ont
conduit à plusieurs milliers de morts
des enfants des femmes des enseignants
des humanitaires des journalistes de
faire face quotidiennement à une
violence inouïe ce que récemment
d'importantes protestations populaires
ont mis en exergue d'importantes
violations de l'état de droit de la part
du régime de paul biya
la captivité forcée est son principal
opposant maurice kamto en est un parfait
exemple
monsieur le ministre la france est
attendu attendu au cameroun ce dont j'ai
envie de même de dire espérer au
cameroun
si le président macron a haussé le ton
en début d'année pour réagir aux
massacres perpétrés dans les zones
anglophones
depuis lors la france reste muette quand
on l'entend pas suffisamment afin de
réduire les inégalités dans la région me
les présente bien et a dit qu'ils ont de
pouvoir promulguer un projet de loi sur
la décentralisation et d'autre part
maurice kamto demande pour sortir de
cette crise la mise en place d'une
commission d' enquête internationale et
interpelle le gouvernement de paul
hier à conclure avec les séparatistes un
cessez-le-feu immédiat
je voudrais monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui
que vous nous fassiez un point sur les
relations de la france avec le cameroun
actuellement et de quelle manière la
france intervient auprès du gouvernement
camerounais afin de permettre à ce pays
proches de la france de sortir de cette
crise profonde et vous demande si vous
entendez soutenir la proposition de
maurice kamto merci merci beaucoup chers
collègues merci à vous tous pour vos
questions
alors je vais donc laisser répondre
monsieur le ministre si je vais essayer
de répondre n'excusons d'être parfois un
peu qu'on s'y étendait l'énorme variété
des questions qui sont qui sont posées
et je ne suis pas encore tout à fait en
cyclo pedic mais met donc je vais de
monsieur bourlanges moi je trouve pas
qu'on soit dans la sphère cela ne
s'était pas sur la turquie ce nom
c'était sur le excusez-moi concerne
concernant si c'est ça sur la turquie
je ne trouve pas que nous soyons
lénifiant par rapport à notre position à
l'égard de la turquie
je crois avoir dit publiquement pas
uniquement dans cette réunion de la
commission des affaires étrangères mais
publiquement et à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat et dans beaucoup de
déclarations que j'ai pu faire dans la
presse notre fermeté sur le sujet y
compris à l'égard de nos quand je parle
avec mes collègues européens y compris à
l'égard de 2 dans les réunions de l'otan
donc nous avons une grande fermeté sur
la nécessaire clarification de la
position de la turquie
sur le vous avez évoqué la question de
l'arménie nous considérons que le groupe
de minsk qui a été mandatée par l'ouest
est l'organisation la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
nous devons assumer notre responsabilité
dans le cadre de ce groupe qui doit
rendre ses comptes à l'eau et c'est eux
nous avons notre propre poids politique
dans cette affaire
sans doute avons-nous peut-être moins de
force que les russes sur sept dans cette
région mais nous avons un poids
politique qui nous permet de tenir notre
place et c'est ce que nous avons essayé
de faire pendant toute cette période est
ce que nous allons continuer à continuer
à faire c'est la turquie qui fait ses
choix c'est pas nous si elle décide de
faire les choix de confrontation nous en
tirerons les conséquences
et vous avez évoqué la question de la
frégate de la frégate française
récemment illuminé pour prendre les
expressions militaire qui convienne par
une frégate turque
pour nous l'incident n'est pas compagnie
n'est pas bouclé et il ne nous avons
transmis cette nos protestations au
niveau de l'otan est ce toujours en
instruction et jouf et on a mis en place
de nouvelles procédures pour éviter ce
genre de situations jose 2 signale par
ailleurs que dans une autre mission qui
est s'appelle la mission irigny une
frégate allemande qui a été elle-même en
difficulté à l'égard par rapport à des
bateaux turcs qu'ils devaient vérifier
et inspecté il ya peu de temps donc nous
avons une posture de fermeté dans cette
dans ces situations on va voir ce que la
turquie va pouvoir
comment elle va se positionner et nous
avons à cet égard le choix d'une
solidarité européenne pour être en
capacité d'entraîner l'ensemble de nos
collègues dans une posture de clarté à
l'égard des initiatives diverses que
peuvent aujourd'hui reprendre initié la
turquie excusez moi mais je commence à
avoir un peu de difficulté de gorge
ensuite monsieur fuchs sur la côte
d'ivoire mais je réponds d'ailleurs en
même temps de la de vous à d'autres
questions qui m'ont été posées sur le
sujet j'ai dit que notre posture c'est l
apaisement et que dans le cas de
l'apaisement il ya des initiatives
politiques à prendre de la part du
président ouattara c'est ce que nous
souhaitons nous baisser l'initiative du
président de le faire des initiatives
ont déjà été prises mais il faut que
nous pensons qu'il faut renforcer ses
attitudes je l'évoquais déjà tout à
l'heure dans une réponse je le maintiens
la sous réserve que cela se fasse dans
le respect du droit constitutionnel
il ya un droit constitutionnel est un
état de droit en côte d'ivoire qui doit
être respecté par tous et c'est un point
important puisque le règlement des
différends entre les autorités
ivoiriennes et l'opposition doit se
faire dans ce cadre donc voilà ce que je
peux dire a ajouté j'espère que là le
bon sens l'emportera concernant la
réforme constitutionnelle du tchad au
nom du principe de non ingérence et on
ne peut pas à la fois dire occupez-vous
de tels pays est en toc dire vous fait
de l'ingérence c'est ya un respect à
avoir de l'indépendance du sud du tchad
si le chat va changer sa constitution ça
le sert le concerne et souhaite qu'il le
fasse le mieux possible
oui mais sur la diplomatie culturelle
proposée par madame genetet jeu
je suis dans l'hésitation ce que j'ai
pas très bien compris ce qu'elle voulait
dire si c'est le fait que le nous la
question religieuse fait partie des
l'appréciation que nous faisons de
l'inde relation avec des différents pays
oui nous avons au quai d'orsay un poste
de conseiller des affaires religieuses
qui intervient sur les relations en
particulier avec le avec le vatican nous
avons avec eux l'arabie séoudite des
discussions sur la régulation des
pèlerinages sur la question de la
formation des imams
mais il n'y a pas au sens propre du
terme une problématique religieuses de
notre relation de nos relations
diplomatiques donc il faut à mon avis
inverse en sorte de ne pas avoir de
confusion
l'add-on religieuse ces partis de si on
doute à la madame politique aussi
monsieur laserman sur le maurice conto
nous avons des positions très claires
sur la nécessité de faire en sorte que
la démocratie fonctionne le au cameroun
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises que je ne serais pas allé au
cameroun si monsieur comme taux n'avait
pas été libéré j'ai attendu qu'il soit
libéré pour me rendre au cameroun et à
l'époque où je suis allé nous étions
dans une phase de d'accalmie et
délibérations étaient intervenus dont
celle de maurice kamto
mais la situation s'est de nouveau tendu
vous avez raison de le dire depuis le
mois de septembre
et donc nous nous souhaitons que les
autorités camerounaises prennent des
initiatives de gestes d'ouverture pour
rétablir la confiance sur la scène de
politique intérieure et qu'elle libère
les personnes arrêtées dans le cadre de
manifestations caractère politique de la
république l'a rappelé je crois vous je
crois que c'est madame politique il a
rappelé ou monsieur vase hermann dans un
interview à jeune afrique il ya quelques
jours et nous sommes dans cette logique
la une ces messages sont très ferme à
l'égard des autorités camerounaises sur
le mercosur
je vais pas reprendre là maintenant
monsieur va zermane toutes les raisons
qui nous amène à être contre le fait que
ce don contre ce projet d'accord
aujourd'hui parce que nous considérons
que ce projet ne permet pas de d'écarter
le risque de déforestation dans en
amérique du sud ne constitue pas un
levier suffisant pour la prise en compte
du dérèglement climatique et de la
protection de la biodiversité dont nous
ne pouvons pas soutenir le projet de
mercredi ou tel qu'il est aujourd'hui ne
sommes pas isolés loin de là sur ce
sujet monsieur dumont leur largeur
nettement je n'ai pas d'informations
spécifiques sur la directi l'application
du doute ifri dans ferroviaire je
pourrais regarder si je vous comprends à
peu près comment ça peut se passer mais
on va regarder comment on peut faire sur
la turquie depuis 2016 tout est arrêté
donc concernant l'adhésion potentiel de
la turquie donc s'est arrêté donc il n'y
a pas nécessité de
reprendre des choses qui sont arrêtés et
suspendu dans l'état actuel des choses
donc constatons que s'est arrêté sur la
suisse concernant le ski mais il y avait
aussi une autre
j'ai eu mon collègue suisse hier soir
sur le sujet c'est une question que se
pose le gouvernement fédéral en ce
moment même parce qu il ya d autres des
questions de compétence c'est vrai que
c'est la compétence des cantons
mais il ya aussi une compétence fédérale
sur un certain nombre de sujets et donc
la question de l'harmonisation de des
décisions prises par la part la suisse
concernant les espaces skiable en
relation avec la france
ils ont ils on parle en ce moment donc
je veux pas anticiper les souhaité qu'on
puisse avoir une collaboration une
cohérence il ya ça existe dans
l'autriche à mon avis ne sont pas prêts
de d'ouvrir face de rose de la
responsabilité on repasse se mêler de
leur choix mais vu l'augmentation de la
pandémie en ce moment en europe
je suis allé à berlin avant-hier vers la
maintenant un niveau de contamination
supérieure à paris là maintenant
donc on est dans une phase d'explosion
ou bien se rendre compte et donc après
chacun prend ses responsabilités et nous
nous considérons le président république
l'a dit hier qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures de précaution et si possible
harmonisée sur les espaces skiable en
europe c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire aussi avec l'andorre et avec avec
l'espagne sur la partie catalogne aragon
nous sommes en discussion avec eux et
j'espère que nous pourrons aboutir une
solution commune voilà
sur la politique je crois vous avoir
répondu en répondant monsieur laserman
sur la situation de monsieur comme tôt
sur je suis peut-être un petit peu dans
le désordre là maintenant je dire je
vais dire à madame clapot que sur la
relation avec l'egypte c'est vrai que
nous avons une relation forte sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme et sur une
coopération sur les grandes crises
régionales nous avons opérations sur la
libye mis une coopération sur le
processus de paix au proche-orient aux
aveux de relations culturelles qui sont
fortes
également dans le domaine de
l'archéologie en particulier ça
n'empêche pas un blanc-seing sur les
droits de l'homme et nous sommes très
vigilants sur ces points nous dans tous
nos relations dans toutes nos rencontres
nous appelons l'attention des autorités
jpz yen au plus haut niveau sur un
certain nombre de situations de détenus
je pense aux particuliers à la situation
ne sera mise à mort ne sera michel j'en
parle à chaque fois que je le rencontre
mon collègue égyptien il ya eu des
améliorations de sa situation et il a pu
je crois de s'entretenir aussi la
question de la pandémie
il se pose je crois qu'il a pu se
retenir avec au téléphone avec sa
compagne céline lebrun et noomi des bons
et des nos militants pour qu'ils
puissent se rencontrer dans le cadre
d'une situation est un peu compliquée
parce que dans le monde doit pu voyager
en cette période et nous sommes très
attentifs sur la décision qui a été
prise à l'égard de l'ol j'ai initiative
égyptienne
nous avons fait une déclaration publique
vous ai eu
il ya eu une mise il y a eu en plus une
action de nos ambassadeurs en poste
notre ambassadeur en poste au caire avec
de ses collègues européens en poste au
caire pour alerter les autorités
égyptiennes sur les risques et le côté
un peu c'est préoccupant de la décision
qu'ils ont prise à l'égard de cette ong
égyptiennes monsieur quentin la position
de la france concernant le concept
d'autonomie stratégique à la suite des
déclarations de la ministre allemand de
la défense
a été exprimée par le président de la
république je veux dire que votre
référence monsieur cantat doit être si
je peux me permettre une lecture
attentive d'une tribune commune que j'ai
pu rendre public avec mon collègue et
comme as à la fois dans un grand journal
du soir français et dans la presse
allemande et américaine où on explique
l'un et l'autre ensemble notre position
et cette position elle est aussi validé
à la fois par la chancelière et par le
président de la république française sur
l'autonomie stratégique y compris en
termes militaires
donc je vous renvoie à cette déclaration
qui n'est pas exactement dans la même
ligne que celle exprimée dans sa
première déclaration par la ministre
allemande de la défense sur taïwan
je crois ma voix vous avoir déjà dit me
semble c'était pas à vous quand ça
concerne la participation de taiwan à
certains organismes internationaux en
particulier le ms nous étions favorables
parce que nous sommes favorables à ce
que tous les acteurs qui peuvent lutter
collectivement pour contrôler les
pandémies que soit la commune 19 ou
autres soient partie prenante et nous
avons regretté que taiwan et pays axé
participer aux travaux de la 73e
assemblée mondiale de la santé qui s'est
tenu du 9 au 13 novembre nous
continuerons d'appeler à la mise en
oeuvre d'un arrangement entre pékin et
tags et taipei qui permettent la barre
décision de taiwan à la prochaine
assemblée mondiale de la santé comme ce
fut le cas auparavant bray il avait
trouvé une solution et nous souhaitons
que cela puisse se faire
on ne peut pas avoir de vide sanitaire
dans la lutte contre la pandémie et donc
ils n'apportent que taiwan soit partie
prenante de ces orientations sur la
situation j'ai pas du bouki sur la
situation à djibouti sinon on aboutit à
6 g pardon monsieur cantat vous dit vous
vous rappeler l'importance de notre
présence le fait que nous ayons un
accord de défense
vous rappeler que nous ne sommes plus
seuls à djibouti c'est vrai il ya du
monde on vous avait parlé des chinois
mais il ya aussi le japonais
il ya aussi les américains c'est
vraiment un lieu de qui devient de plus
en plus stratégique que tout le monde
veut être présent sauf que nous avons
non seulement l'ancienneté mais nous
avons aussi le nombre et nous avons
aussi l'insertion dans la vie et dans la
dans le pays puisque les militaires
français qui sont basés à djibouti sont
aussi accompagnés de leurs familles dont
nous avons une une longue histoire de
présence et de confiance avec ce pays et
qui est aussi partie prenante de la
francophonie nous avons un lycée que
fréquentent beaucoup de djiboutiens qui
va être rénovée bientôt von arx pas
bandant 2021 et dans le domaine
économique il faut que sans doute que
nous renforcions notre présence mais je
ne suis pas inquiet sur la qualité de
notre relation avec avec ce pays même si
on voit bien qu'il ya là une zone de
compétition importante
je sais que par ailleurs des grands
clubs français s'intéressent à des
projets structurants sur l'avenir de
ceux de ce pays donc sommes tout à fait
soucieux de garantir la souveraineté de
ceux de ce pays et d'éviter aussi qu'il
ne puisse mettre en péril sa
souveraineté par un recours excessif à
l'endettement
stimulé par une intervention extérieure
qui ne serait pas la nôtre vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
j'imagine sur eux sur l'intervention de
marion laine donc sur la suisse j'ai
répondu sur le sur le financement notre
participation au fida je devrais dire
d'abord que certes le fida est un outil
important notre action de lutte contre
la pauvreté et la faim en milieu rural
ce n'est pas le seul mais c'est un outil
important et nous sommes nous avons pour
la période 2010 9 2021
apportez 46,6 milliards millions
millions et 1,2 contribution plus des
prêts aux conditions très favorables de
50 millions par l'afd et nous sommes
dans les six premiers contributeurs
donc je voulais donc vous vous le
préciser est précisé aussi que dans les
orientations de l'aide publique au
développement nous avons consacré 2 869
millions à de notre app aider à la
sécurité alimentaire n'est pas
uniquement par le fida parce que vous
comparez dix ans dans tel pays on met
dans tel le fonds mettant un tel pays
hôte remettant mais dans d'autres fonds
on est davantage forza on a un choix une
orientation de de notre bouquet
d'intervention sur l'aide alimentaire
qui est de notre responsabilité
le fida ya sa place et globalement la
france a consacré 869 millions d'euros à
son app et des sur la sécurité
alimentaire soit 12% de plus par rapport
à 2018
et ce près de +2 6% de notre république
que de développement global donc ce qui
montre que notre intérêt sur les enjeux
alimentaire et nutrition sont tout à
fait essentiel monsieur clément sur le
la sphère de ville peinte
nous avons pris des mesures à la suite
de cette affaire
nous avons sanctionné l'iran par des
musiques des sanctions que nous avons
mises en oeuvre en particulier services
du renseignement et donc les initiatives
ont été prises de manière très ferme à
l'égard de ceux de ce pays concerne la
suite de cette tentative d'attentât
et nous sommes très vigilants sur la
situation de notre compatriote fariba
adelkhah que vous avez évoqué de la même
manière nous sommes très vigilants sur
l'évolution de la situation de madame se
doutait même si elle a été libéré à la
suite de toute une pression qu'ils ont
pu faire en sa faveur je vous rappelle
que c'est elle qui ait bénéficié du prix
franco-allemand des droits de l'homme
l'année dernière sur madame liliane à
tanguy concernant le parquet européen
il existe aujourd'hui mais son rôle
concerne seulement la protection des
intérêts financiers l'union européenne
et dans ce contexte pose la question de
l'extension de compétence du parquet
européen la lutte contre le terrorisme
le président de l'udc s'est déclarée
favorable
il l'a dit déjà dans son discours de la
sorbonne est ce la situation de
développement du terrorisme en europe et
la volonté de la commission européenne
d'avoir un ensemble de d'action contre
le terrorisme qui va être soumis
le 9 décembre
ce engagement sera je pense manifesté à
cette occasion mais nous sommes
favorables à cette dimension là et sur
la pêche crois que j'ai répondu tout à
l'heure attendons la fin de la
discussion
mais il y aura des mesures de
conservation qui ce compris s'il n'y a
pas d'accord et des mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont prises très
rapidement et pas de préférence au
niveau européen avec des engagements
financiers qui sont quand même très très
significatif
je dernière sur la madame le pen
mécanisme d'inclusion carbone nous
sommes en discussion dans franck riester
manie de discussions dans le cadre de la
revue de la politique commerciale
européenne
c'est un travail qui a été lancée par la
commission au mois de juin dernier et
cette révision intervient à un moment
crucial qui marqué par les conséquences
de la crise sanitaire mais aussi de la
crise climatique et nous entendons
mettre dans cette révision les enjeux
d'un comme les enjeux commerciaux les
enjeux environnementaux pour permettre
le mécanisme d'inclusion carbone va être
mise en oeuvre est d'atteindre son
efficacité sur monsieur monsieur nadeau
je crois que j'ai répondu un tout à
l'heure sur alpha condé vous n'était
peut-être pas l' écoute mais je crois
que j'ai déjà parlé deux fois d'alpha
condé et maing il ne mérite pas lui que
je lui en parle d'une troisième fois
voilà c'était une forme de punition pour
me succombé enfin sur le sur le
haut-karabagh pour monsieur mer nous
devons rentrer dans une logique de
discussion dans laquelle on aurait dû
rentrer déjà depuis un certain temps et
s'il y a eu une situation de guerre
c'est en partie parce que les acteurs
sans doute avons nous aussi notre part
de responsabilité puisque nous sommes co
présidents du groupe qui devait faire en
sorte qu' une solution puisse se trouver
mais les acteurs ne se sont pas mis
ensemble pour essayer de discuter du
statut de cette de cet espace du haut
karabagh et c'est maintenant la
nécessité d'agir qui s'imposent
mais on ne peut le faire vraiment
monsieur merck lorsque les conditions
sanitaires et humanitaires auront été
réhabilité aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
deux arméniens qui se sont réfugiés en
arménie qui normalement résider et
habite de haut karabakh donc il faut
reconstituer la vie de ce pays de ces
territoires par an pour que l'on puisse
avoir ensuite une discussion pour le
statut définitif de ceux de ce
territoire sur la présence militaire
c'est difficile maintenant d'intervenir
pour avoir une présence supplémentaire
de
de qui il faudrait remettre peut-être
les forces des nations unies mais à
partir du moment où l'eau et c'est eux
valide le processus qui met en place je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de raison de
revenir là dessus sur le g20 monsieur
julien laferrière moi je suis pas je ne
suis pas si pessimiste que vous certes
le g20 n'a pas donné des résultats
exceptionnels mais il n'empêche que sur
la santé je pense que les engagements
pris par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du g20 de garantir un accès
équitable aux remèdes dent contre le
comité de lakovic 19 de soutenir
l'initiative acte a de ce fait de
soutenir la facilité kovacs de diffusion
des vaccins de faire en sorte que ce
soit bien public mondial tout ça va
plutôt bien on n'aurait pas pu avoir ces
accords loeb antérieurement en raison de
l'affrontement sino américain sur le ms
en particulier donc ça c'est un point
d'avancé sur le climat il ya eu du
progrès puisque par rapport au g20
d'osaka puisque tous les signataires se
sont engagés à réviser à la hausse leurs
contributions nationales dans la
perspective de la coop 26 et en fait
j'ai évoqué cette question climatique
tout à l'heure parce que le nouvelle
administration américaine veut de
nouveau rentrer dans le désaccord de
bovero venir dans les accords de paris
et puis sur la dette il ya eu quand même
un accord de prolongation de la
suspension du service de la dette et la
volonté d'agir dans le cadre comme de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un cadre
commun entre le g20 et le club de paris
pour définir des critères pour le
traitement des dettes à venir ça c'est
plutôt positif même si sur d'autres
points
on n'a pas été aussi loin que nous
souhaitions mais c'était
par rapport au jeu trouve au chai 20
précédents c'était mieux c'était aussi
difficile d'avoir g20 qui avancent
beaucoup parce que j'ai vu en visio
c'est pas facile pour avoir des
négociations et des discussions sur le
contenu je trouve que dans le contexte
est pas si mauvais vous avez évoqué la
situation en arabie saoudite
j'ai pas reprendre tous les propos parce
que sur le yémen je me suis déjà exprimé
à plusieurs reprises je conçois très
bien qu'on parle du de l'arabie saoudite
qui à l'égard du yémen
je pense qu'on oublie peut-être vous
même aussi qu' il ya aussi des aussi
qu'ils sont aux films qui sont alimentés
militairement parlant
pourtant pas le yémen faut parler de
tout et donc je fais en sorte de parler
de tout dans cette situation et en
sachant qu'aujourd'hui la rabhi séoudite
cherchent désormais ce n'était pas le
cas où tout le temps une seule sortie de
crise politique alors que son territoire
continuent à faire l'objet de
bombardements des outils avec de
l'armement iranien voilà donc il faut
tout dire à un moment donné je me
permets de le faire même si haut sur la
question que vous soulevez et sur les
situations de des femmes en arabie
séoudite sur la tête sur la situation de
madame à la toul en particulier il faut
être très clair et très fermes sur notre
position est de le dire régulièrement
aux autorités saoudiennes c'est ce que
nous faisons
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs qui ont tangué fini bon j'ai
pas fini
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
bon je pense que quand même on va vous
remercier pour votre disponibilité
merci beaucoup et donc la séance est
levée merci à vous chers collègues